hello everybody
welcome back to frenemies the show
hosted by
two skinny people no we're skinny this
week you've been on a diet for a week
i've been working out for a week
straight
can you show that can people i'm not on
a diet i think i've been working out
you're on a diet i've been working out
for a week straight and i
do feel like my waist has lost some
interest i don't want to i don't want to
tear you down at the beginning of the
show already
damn i was calling you skinny too i know
i can't tell but apparently you've been
on a diet yeah
i don't feel skinny listen
so much sometimes you look bigger
there's no fluctuation it's all upwards
but we're both skinny this week because
you were consistently on a diet for a
week i've been consistently working out
for a week so we're both very skinny
today so congratulations
can i just see what drink that is yeah
this is called the wedding cake
frappuccino
i don't wanna i don't wanna be
judgmental i just wanna know what you're
drinking
no bente vanilla bean cream frappe
four pumps white mocha single caramel
drizzle three pumps of caramel syrup
nice it's for tick-tock it's a tick-tock
trend it's for tick-tock
this is this is monday's are my treat
days because it's the day i'm like i'm
excited to come here it's my happy day
so we
have a little snack before we have a
snack it's like what you eat what did
you eat
well we didn't eat a snack oh well i had
these peanut butter passover cookies but
what are we oh i had oatmeal this
morning no that wasn't my treat no my
treat is after like yesterday after the
show
we went to arby's and got mozzarella
sticks and curly fries which we could do
today honestly those curly fries are so
good
and that was our snack and then when i
go home i cook for my video so we have
like a fun day okay so you haven't eaten
yet today
um i had oatmeal and i got these
passover i'm just wiping this down
okay oh okay why are these passover
cookies what makes them passover
because there's no bread there's no uh i
think they're delicious i won't eat it
but
it's coconut and peanut butter instead
of flour because us
jews i don't care about it about thank
you for including me in that
oh no it was that's not what i meant
that's really
like no i meant like me and the other
jews i have who's wearing a high today
oh yeah me where's your star of david
can't identify you yeah i don't want to
be identified trust me last people
started identifying jews it wasn't good
no thanks that's why they did it in the
holocaust that's why they put the star
of david on them yeah i'll bet you i bet
you when nazis start rounding up jews
again you're gonna take that guy off
real fast
you're gonna be like i'm not a jew i
swear to god i'm not a jew yeah we'll
see how cute it is
your little jewish fashion accessories
are when they start rounding us up
speaking of jewelry sponsored by upstart
oh sponsored by upstart
and let's stop eating seafood
because the fishermen did you watch
conspiracy
yeah oh my gosh because of the
fisherman's nets that are causing it not
straws
do all the straws you will maybe don't
do the straws but really should stop
eating seafood
dude jews are ahead of their time they
stopped eating bottom feeders a long
time ago
right well we eat fish stop it
right stop it stop it well luckily i
don't even like seafood but
first of all i did watch see spirit see
it's this new netflix
uh documentary about how like the ocean
is dying because we're eating fish
and there's a lot of good points made
but these kite
these types of documentaries always kind
of make me
like the message i take well
but i always feel like they're so
alarmist that i take i take it with a
grain of salt
but like for example one thing that they
said that i thought was really
interesting is that half the plastic
pollution
in the ocean is fishing nets as you said
i was like oh [ __ ] that
yeah straws are like little like helps
the point zero zero it's like i don't
[ __ ] paper straws you know what i mean
it's crazy and they're selling these
like people in japan
japan i'm talking to you stop buying the
three million dollar
blue seared puna they'll never stop
eating seafood
do you think the people in japan are
watching no
you don't think they know them or china
that doesn't have youtube one of them
don't china doesn't have youtube but i
don't think either are really watching
in numbers that we could have any
influence over we never see japanese
people come for us like they don't like
stan us i never see that anywhere
well they yeah i don't koreans do i see
the bts stand sometimes come for us or
like
support us on twitter oh we do they have
like the bts like jihoon in the thing
but they'll be like we love for enemies
but
i love i love army
i'm a huge bts fan yeah
i embrace everything listen yes i think
it's cool i think it's a cool new crave
i i welcome the the k-pop invasion i
love it i like the diversity of culture
and i can speak korean
[Music]
what you can't tell me what you said no
if you're not a real k-pop stand then
right did you say
anything yeah okay there's some random
[ __ ]
hannah dulce net okay stop
you gotta pick your identity i love no
first of all my therapist says i don't
because i talked about how i had my
identity since i was eight years old and
like you know what
sometimes you just don't know your own
identity in life i'm talking about like
jewish or korean
that's why i do it because i don't have
an identity on my own this is a real
thing that people suffer from some
people really never know who they are
they have no identity
my whole life you have an oh you have an
identity it's other people's identity
it's whoever
you got an identity girl damn you got
identity of the
wazoo in that in itself is that an
identity not having an identity
oh that's because that's my identity
okay that's a real thing i thought i'm
it's a real thing
based in love no even my whole life
people that that's why i've always
dressed in costume like i literally have
no idea who i am like if you say who's
trash i'm i try to do 23andme
confuse me even more you're a blonde
what what's your
youtube thing blonde mj that's who you
are
username yeah thank you would you have
got in bed with mj
oh um michael jackson yeah yeah
i i always fantasize that moses michael
jackson he looks like him kind of wait
you always fantasize you were molested
by much no
that moses said moses is like you
fantasize that moses is michael jackson
yeah for our valentine's day
you guys role play that yeah he'll come
did you see our tick tock on valentine's
day we were role-playing you are not
alone wait you still have a michael
jackson uh
fetish um i think he's good looking i
probably shouldn't i need to know i
think he was handsome like yeah but i
don't think you can say that
anymore like would you like his hands no
i just think woody allen was handsome
and i think i can't say that anymore
because that's like what
you could right you know i mean that
inspired me to adopt that documentary i
think we might adopt
say what i might have to adoption mia
pharaoh adopted all those kids and maybe
i should oh yeah
kind of yeah adoption is a really it's
like one of the most pure
acts a person can do you know but i
heard it seriously this is an all
seriousness like if you have a mental
health illness like if you have a mental
illness they don't let you adopt them
like if you're
like they're like nah we'd rather let
this baby starve and than uganda isn't
that [ __ ] that is true
but that's so messed up like if you're
not married well obviously it's me or
ferocious but if you're not married you
have a lower chance and if you have
mental illness it's a lower chance of
getting kids over here
and i think you guys will be fine
because you have like a good financial
support system and we thought about i'm
thinking about it for real cause i don't
know if i have kids
um well you should there's you have
there's like
what you should go like ivf could just
go all out and see if it works
ugh i'd rather just like adopt a kid
that like maybe needs me you know
well that's a great option too yeah i
don't want to do the baby stage i'll
take a five-year-old like give me after
the baby stage see that
makes that's a red flag for me well just
because i think it's gonna be a lot
maybe you shouldn't adopt
i wanna get uh don't tell the adopting
recruiter that
i wanna i'm definitely not gonna be i'm
sure that nobody wants a dot from i
don't know what that country is but tell
me
i want to adopt i want to adopt from a
more exotic country that nobody's had
i'm thinking maybe
and anyone over five i am not changing
diapers they'd be like
no you're getting it all wrong people
don't they want babies to raise so a lot
of kids over five don't get adopted yeah
you foster
so that's what i'm saying is i want to
take the ones that like nobody wants i
want to take those people you know
i don't know like what the statistics
are country-wise but i know age-wise the
older they are the harder it is to adopt
them
i'm not going to adopt a teenager i'll
adopt a 13-year-old like i'm down like
you know what i mean like
maybe a five and a 13 year old from some
country that nobody wants maybe like
what's a country nobody wants to be at
maybe um i wouldn't
specifically name anyone at this point
yeah what about like north korea nobody
wants to be in north korea they're not
i don't think they let adoption i don't
think they have public adoption
uh they don't you can't adopt from
really no you can't even leave north
korea they should gun you down
but on on a knight sir note we did a
charity drive last week
where we donated twenty thousand and the
frenemy's foot soldier
who raised almost fifty thousand dollars
for victims of sexual violence man you
guys
that's amazing that's crazy thousand
what's up what's up what's up what's up
what's up
oh that's amazing how's the weinstein
one doing did anyone donate more into
that dude we are crushing weinstein like
you all mirror max
come here max yeah team rank here let's
just see the team ranks just because
like look i know it's like charity we're
not supposed to flex on
on everyone but like we kind of are kind
of dominating everybody
like you need to flex so they work
harder like hey mirror max we're
crushing you
miramax didn't even they didn't even put
up a thumbnail it's like sorry guys you
like
harvey weinstein and yeah one of their
friend of wants the h3 podcast
so why don't we have a friend of mine's
logo it does i mean
we don't have a logo i get it no we're
just gonna fit you just want a picture
of your face
we have a logo yeah that's the logo of
the channel
right now it's not about that it's not
about that it's about a group collection
but anyway 50 000 that's so great you
guys man come on come on
donate to rain i always think of rain
wilson i always think it's like a
charity for him
when i look at it he's the most prolific
predator we've ever known
no no no i'm getting i'm kidding just
saying like this is a
sorry rain wilson this this is a whole
charity just about supporting his
victims
do you think he's funny probably i'm a
victim because his comedy sucks i hate
white shirts so much
what i hate that character i think
that's the most annoying character on tv
i hate it i wouldn't blame him i love
the office i
wait white is so funny okay let's let's
move on we have we're doing the oddly
satisfying
i'm sorry to cut you off but somebody
has to keep us on the reels a little bit
because the last time we went too long
and we didn't get to do the oddly
satisfying that all these guys have
prepped
we're gonna do it together yeah because
we have like bonus bonus people here
today to help us and i feel like last
time they were probably like oh my god
listen to them talk for two hours
i know they're getting paid to be here
but still i felt really badly good they
came here to like help and set up and
so i have some top of the show stuff to
get to real fast
congratulations you got your first dose
of vaccine we'd love to see that we love
vaccinations here on the frenemies
podcast
how was it did you get a lolly um no i
got chicken parmesan
at where do we go after they gave you
chicken parmesan
it was right next door they had a
magiano so we went to dude that's hella
dope tell me where you got your shot
at kaiser permanente in woodland hills
and right next door is the maggiano's
and we got chicken parmesan
oh yeah i asked if they gave you a
lollipop not chicken parmesan
oh i thought you said what did i get
after a molly
a lolly like a lollipop like you know
when you get a shot you get a little oh
oh i was thinking of like the lolly
steak lollipops
yeah okay like a lamb chop lolly so i
see you got moderna that's what i got
he got he got the lollies he got the
lamb chops lollipops okay
bro you're on some weird food rabbit
hold on i can't follow you down
food i don't even know what the [ __ ]
you're talking about oh good i mean
i make such good food i got this oh i'm
on this new diet where people deliver me
food now
every meal seven days a week three meals
a day it's all super healthy honestly it
tastes pretty good but
i sit there i'm like so sad oh really
and then everybody like ella's mom's
cooking all this crazy food i'm like
how are you doing that when someone
cooks oh i couldn't that's really sad
i just sit there like a why didn't you
wait until after like so you don't smell
the food i can't wait
i'm too fat it needs to happen now but
you're working out
no i'm not do you have a you told me you
had a trainer
yeah i do but i've only done it once is
it a man or a woman it's a guy and he's
like 23 and god bless the soul but it's
like
i have a little okay i'm what is it he's
nice and good
i'm gonna keep working with him but like
there's something about a 23 year old
just being like
me 35 collapsed on the floor after
planking for 30 seconds like in fetal
position like
on the verge of having a heart attack
and then being like money dude
that was money good job who's your
trainer
he's just some kid he's like 23 year old
kid how did you find him though
lena found it for us okay cool so he
just showed up 30 seconds
is good you only did like 15 seconds on
our computer
i was just like he's like
good job buddy he's like 30 seconds come
on and i only can only do 20 seconds
he's like money baby
i was like stop for me it's just like
this is a nightmare and he's taught and
he's like
he's like talking to my corpse like
money baby
i don't know like i know he's trying to
be encouraging and i like that yeah i
don't like that either i don't like it
it's fake yeah because it's not money
just be like yeah
just call it what it is no that's sad
i want to hear it it's like we're like
in the first weekend biggest loser right
and those guys are like collapsing
that's us and you know what jillian
michael says
get your fat ass up you're disgusting oh
i don't hear that
i wouldn't mind it but just be like good
job you know you're going to get better
or just just watch me in silence
just silence and horror i don't know if
i need someone to
actually like just ridicule me yeah i
don't think
you fat [ __ ] that's what million
michaels does on biggest losers spit on
me instead of
saying i'm money sounds like a kink oh
yeah
um i have a challenge for
a friend of mine we should we should go
be firefighters for a day
brah who's going to let us do that like
the fire department can we donate some
money and like
see if they let us be firefighters for
it it'll be awesome if we actually get
called to a rescue situation
and there's someone like an actual
distress i mean you are like the stooges
in our [ __ ] i would save them yeah
i would save them also i have another
idea there's a flash cut to us being
needing to be saved and the person dying
and stuff um i have another idea
how about okay i feel like i this is a
really good idea like anxiety workbooks
have been working wonders people are
like so you seem so much happier and
stable
i do the anti-anxiety work work but it's
not like totally all there yet
we need like a frenemies anti-anxiety
notebook for people who are also like
fat and have other issues going on like
hearing voices i'm fat like i have
childhood trauma
and all of that in one with the
anti-anxiety notebook it'll be like all
yours what are you talking what is the
anti-anxiety notebook you never got an
anti-anxiety notebook
no they're so good they're so like when
you're anxious like they give you
exercises to like calm you down and it's
good like if you're getting triggered
like it's the trigger no you just write
down you're like hey
no they give you proms they'll be like
you know um
what are you feeling right now that
you're triggered they're like is this a
real
is this real or is this you know like
something that maybe when you wake up
tomorrow you'll feel fine like it gives
you like steps like cake or whatever
and we need to do that but for like
people that like also have trauma
because yes it helps me
but also it doesn't cope with the fact
that like i want to eat to like cope
with this trauma
so instead so then you need like a part
two to be like okay you're going through
this trauma you're going through these
triggers i'm recognizing this but now i
want to eat so
so to help my eating disorder we need
like a second half so that where the
friend of musings anxiety notebook comes
in so now so now it's for people with
anxiety and eating disorder so it's like
a one cloud thing
how many pages is this when you're done
well the the book i have is only like
300 but if we do a friend of mine's
anti-exide notebook it could be like a
600 page one because it's for people
with all the problems
oh my god so it helps you cope with your
coping so we're selling this for really
[ __ ] up people who need 600 pages
worth of pages
do you want to do one thank you wait
wait anything you want to sell like
anxiety
we should do one we should write one
together on how we deal with our
like you know stressors and then when
other stressors come and help us so like
right okay i deal with my triggers
really well now i don't have manic
episodes my problem is now i eat to
cover that up
so now we need to do another layer you
know and like what can you do to stop
binging and control your anxiety oh my
god
yeah it's like oh good i got too many
problems oh and then we could put like
jug like juggle balls with it i don't
really
i have to be honest i don't really know
what you're talking about you've never
done anti-anxiety notebook
no it's like a big thing like therapists
give people there's like i have like so
many of them at my house that's so weird
i'm supposed to never done one i've
never done one it's like a choose your
own adventure of like neurosis it sounds
like yeah
oh okay i love that well i got bit by a
dog
over the weekend oh i saw that what was
that oof what did i really see it but i
saw it big-ass german shepherd
where it was [ __ ] insane and um
we were just like having a good friday
evening because hila's mom's here and
she was with deep watching theodore at
night
let's go for a drive we take our dogs go
for a drive we're we're going through
like the fanciest neighborhood i've ever
seen in bel air where all the houses are
like
you know when you're in a there's like
nice neighborhoods and then there's like
neighborhoods that are so nice you can't
even see the house you know yeah
it's just like just edges it's like one
of those yeah
and so it's like 1am
and i see this huge [ __ ] dog i
thought it was a coyote because
but i was like oh my god it's too big i
saw a collar i was like oh my god it's a
giant german shepherd
and it must be escaped from someone's
yard
oh no so i get really worried and you
know i love my dog so i was like
i can't i could consciously leave this
dog here in this situation because
if somebody saw my dogs i would kiss
their feet
if they did everything they could to
rescue my dog so i get out
i'm trying to befriend this dog is sweet
dog
um but just a little nervous didn't want
to approach me
and then i see another huge german
shepherd coming down the road i was like
what the [ __ ] is going on
and so i'm like please don't kill me and
then
this second one is really nice and
approaches me
and so then the second one warms up to
me so they're obviously brothers
and then i finally i like they they're
running off and coming back and forth
and i'm chasing them down for like two
hours trying to chase these guys out
ela's in the car with the dogs and
uh these this dog owner is so annoying
because
i finally get like hey buddy how are you
i get his caller so
on his caller i was like there's gonna
be a phone number i'll call the owner
there's this just a tight like smaller
than a dime i'm telling you
this giant german shepherd has a dog tag
smaller than a [ __ ] dime
and on it is a qr code
so i've been there with at night with my
phone and the flash on and
everything's coming out like i'm like
okay hold on and then the dog starts
crying because they want to
escape me and i'm taking all these
photos of this tiny qr code at night
with the flash and
it's all blurry and i'm like [ __ ] this
person so i go
so they run off again and i follow him
down
and i find so then i go back and get
ila's phone because i need the light to
get so that i have one light
and one photo so i can get a clear photo
so i get a clear photo of the qr code
finally and then it's not registered to
anybody
it goes qr code found no registration i
was like
wait what [ __ ] yeah
do you think maybe they were like
murder dogs like those blood dogs no
they well we the whole we found out who
they own were owned by oh so they were
owned by someone yeah
a good i think a good family wait did
they buy you how do they buy you where
did they okay so
so now i'm like okay so there's no owner
i don't know who the [ __ ] dogs are
the only way to get these dogs
to safety is to get them to
i have to get them in my car and get
them to a vet and get
see if they're microchipped and so
but i have my dogs in the car right and
alfredo
is insane alfredo is the sweetest dog
ever but he turns into cujo when he sees
any other dog i swear to god he's like
the craziest [ __ ] he'll throw
down against anyone
that might be a parenting problem well
he's a stray dog
he has he has some behavior yeah but you
got to like introduce them
okay excuse me i'm not here to get
lectured by you well you could have
saved all the dogs if they were
socialized with them but go ahead so i'm
getting to the point
so i take shredder out who has been
socialized we've had since a puppy and
is generally really good with other dogs
so i'm like okay i'm gonna try to get
shredder out to say hi to these two
feral [ __ ] giant german shepherds um
so i take shredder out and there's one
dog there and they start sniffing and
they're being nice
and then the second dog comes bounding
around the corner up like a cross street
where he was off just [ __ ] around
and trader gets really scared because
they're they're just like on him and
they're sniffing and then shredder
starts to get aggressive
and defensive and then they try to take
a one of them takes a huge bite at
shredder
and so did it bite him well he bit my
finger instead of shredder
so i take shredder up and i was like oh
[ __ ] and held him up like this
and they were trying to jump at jesus i
thought dude i swear to god shredder
could have died and it's fine
they're good dogs i know it's it dogs
get that way it's [ __ ] weird i'm
surprised your hands not more bit
well they were nice dogs and once i i
think he was just trying to kill my dog
real quick
but once i picked him up and i held him
over my head and i was so scared because
he was trying to jump at me and he was
following me and also i was like
i was like okay okay everybody chill i
was like either put down the window i
backed up
the car and i threw shredder in and then
of all people were like
i don't know what to do this is so
[ __ ] up and then ela we were going to
call like animal rescue
or or like non-emergency line but
nothing was open
and so elo of all people thought to call
whitney cummings who does
dog rescue oh and whitney came
with her car and dogs wow oh and so we
sat with the dogs for like 30 minutes
and then whitney came with some dog
treats threw him in the back of her car
the dogs were like super nice they got
right into her car like like didn't even
[ __ ] hesitate here's some treats get
in
so she got the dogs went to her house
put the dogs in her garage
they were happy they were chilling um
and took him to the vet and got
microchipped found the owner
who's like a billionaire apparently oh
he's like the 900th richest person in
the world did you get a reward
i was like hello lawsuit no i'm kidding
did you get a reward
no no i don't offer you money well
whitney is the one who was talking to
him i don't want money what am i doing
i did it i didn't call i did it in the
hopes that if my dog ever gets out
somebody
does the same thing oh that's like what
is that called paying it forward no
like karma it's called both circle of
life though
circle life and shredder gets eaten by a
german shepherd i don't like circle life
no circle of life he survived because he
was in the rolls-royce
eat the rich hmm we're eating the rich
we you well no we don't like that is
that a tea don't eat them you did it you
did you were eating the rich you
remember that tick tock trend you did it
don't eat the ridge oh yeah yeah okay
thank you yes where i was like
eating the rich because right i had a
nice fork or something
so shredder was the fork or the
the other dog was the fork oh god this
analogy is too
extended shredder is the rich because
he's in the rolls-royce so you're eating
shredder
but his dogs are richer your hand is the
fork
those dogs are richer than you those are
billionaire dogs
so that's the tic-tac would work you're
eating the rich but the rich was
actually the stray dogs are you saying i
should have ate the dogs
your hand was the fork should i killed
the dogs those dogs would kill me
they would have killed me and they would
have killed my dog i was scared shitless
anyway this guy your dogs are just i'm
not going to say that cause apparently
yeah they are too little i was i was
ready to i was ready to be like yo i
want these there's too sweet they were
so sweet
i was like i'm about to adopt these dogs
if this guy if we don't find out who
they are but
the owner i'm not going to say his name
i know who he is you know he is
yeah because he's like high profile
johnson johnson yeah he's john and john
his name is he's he's john is it would
you tell me off camera if it was
he's not famous it's not a name you
wouldn't come up with the vaccine
because i just got a vision that he did
no are you how are you [ __ ] no i'm
kidding no you're way off
what do you feel no i also have visions
and for some reason the vaccine guy
no he you wouldn't recognize his name
he's just some finance guy
but he's the 900 i might i've dated a
lot of finance guys in my days okay i'll
tell you off camera
um he's gay i will say i've dated gay
men okay all right stop
you don't know him i guarantee you you
don't can't guarantee it
all right i'll tell you off camera
because i don't want to say his name but
anyway your dogs are kind of pick me
dogs
i love them but definitely pick me dogs
you don't know my dogs how dare you say
that i love them i'm just saying
i think when you start using pikmi about
dogs you've maybe
out used that phrase a little bit
you go this hamburger's such a pick me
wow so whitney cummings is the real hero
and this is
the whitney cummings came she put
through him in the car
damn why don't people talk about that
when they talk about woody because i
don't know whitney but i feel like
there's not really like great stories
that surround her
i know you love her i'm not saying i
don't wanna i don't wanna why people
don't say anything bad about her
um no i just i know one person had like
a backstreet i don't know we're cool now
like i know we have like something or i
had something to her she's probably you
had beef with whitney cuz no i think i
had one sided beef i'm sure she did not
give a [ __ ] about it she's like
wait what was your problem i told you
about this already you did like
anyways i don't want to even bring it up
but i no i anyways she's a saint is what
i'm saying and i'm yeah
i was like oh my god because i was not
gonna leave those dogs there and i was
just in such a bind and then when she
showed up and thrown i was like oh my
[ __ ] god thank you so much
it's funny because you know in the these
dogs caused so much trouble for everyone
and whitney bitched him out by the way
she's like you need to be more
responsible dog owner
your dogs got out my friends had to
follow them for two to three hours and
they don't even have proper color
yes i spent the whole night with these
[ __ ] oh i would've just forget it
circle of life you know
circle of life bye let the coyotes get
them that happened to mustafa
circle of life [ __ ] got ian by hyenas
that's right circle life [ __ ]
that's what i'm gonna start saying to
anything circle life [ __ ]
i like that it's just be like be like yo
listen
i have bad news i have a pancreatic
cancer circle of life [ __ ] off [ __ ]
oh i'd be more sad if you had pancreatic
cancer than that i wouldn't be as like
what's a funnier situation where it's
like a homeless person's like can you
spare some change circle life
[ __ ] off circle life
they don't die oh it's only the homeless
people don't die
um circle of life
i like that though just be like circle
of life [ __ ] although then elton john
replies to us because he wrote it right
doesn't get trademarked
us never know oh i don't think he coined
the term circle of life but he did make
that
song for lanking i got i'm not going to
say the the extra extent of this
situation but i might got charged for my
lawyers
accepting a letter from another lawyer
that was going to sue me and i was like
yeah here's my lawyer's information
whatever and so he's like so my lawyer's
like can we accept this because on
behalf and i was like yeah accept it
whatever
and then they charge me like 600 for
accepting a complaint from another
lawyer
lawyers don't work for free they don't
[ __ ] piss for free lawyers are the
worst i think if you all have a lawyer
on retainer like that's it
well they use the money on retainer and
then when it runs out they charge your
ass
lawyers are are the uh absolute leeches
of the world i mean they
they spend money like at [ __ ]
bro okay don't even get me started on
lawyers can i just clarify something
real quick because i feel like now it's
going to be like left weird and i don't
want to be left away the reason i didn't
like whitney
was because she was crystalia this is
the true story because i was blocked by
crystalia so this was before
i'm like i'm not going to say i'm a
premonitious but i am a premonition
premonitious like the vaccine prediction
look i feel like i'm a little ahead of
my time people say
i've been calling out chris because he
really he texted my sister when she had
freshly turned 18.
oh she was trying to hook up like oh
inappropriately i didn't know that
she was 18 so i'll tell you that
whatever we talked about it on my uh
extinct podcast edition trish we did a
whole episode on it but anyways um
i i already know for life circle life
met him at a bikini contest that i was
in i was in the bikini contest one time
and crystalia was performing there and i
met him there and i also had did he rate
you
um no he didn't rate me he just
performed but he had some inappropriate
how did you get what was your rating
well i don't think it was a rate it
wasn't
it wasn't like a rating i didn't play as
we'll put it that way but it wasn't
okay it was like the mark and brian like
radio bikini contest i
and you had to like apply and i was like
a finalist so i'm not okay good good
good
good getting legend back in the day i
guess but um crystal leah was performing
there and he also was like
he just always was this like person
right and so i've been saying this for a
while so when whitney and him had that
show or whatever i remember i was
tweeting and this is why crystal blocked
me but then i was like oh why is whitney
associating with this person who's a
known
creep it's not like he hit on girls and
girls are like no thank you there were
it was very
aggressive no stop i don't like this and
he keep doing it do you think
it's ironic for you to say that
considering you're friends with shane
for so long
um no because a lot of the shane stuff i
didn't even know
like the stuff that like recently that i
was talked about i didn't even know
about like
until like last year and then i was like
okay i'm gonna be loyal i'm gonna be
loyal
but chris had had these like it's been
like a known thing i get it i totally
agree
i don't think his i don't think his
friends knew the extent of his maybe not
okay i'll give you the
doubts i think they knew that he was
like you know a dog
right like a player sure right i guess
me just not thinking about this this was
when i was like 23 or 24 or something
like that and i was just like okay not
really thinking
27 i don't remember but i was just not
like thinking about it i was just like
this is weird that this girl like goes
so hard for this guy that's unknown like
it just to me it's like okay
i used to work i don't think he was
known at the time to be there he totally
was i worked in the stand-up comp so i
was i was an assistant to josh nasser
like i was like
i used to work in the comedy like field
as far as like being assistants to them
not like being comedian
so you know this like people jamie
kennedy has that same sort of like
reputation like there's like stand-up
comics that are these like
and people know it like obviously they
know it they can say they don't but they
do i guess there's a difference between
sleazy and like
predatory behavior exactly but he was
sleazy
and didn't stop stop stop if you know
what i'm saying so oh oh
yeah so oh yeah that's horrible and so i
so my issue was anyways
i always had this thing with whitney
because she was like putting him on a
platform sort of like
david dom right like you see this person
on a platform and you know how horrible
they've been to girls that you know
personally
and you're just like oh so my issue is
that and so um
when she started her podcast like i
think her podcast people had reached out
to me i was like do you want to come on
whitney's
and i thought it was my podcast company
reaching out to me asking me because
they used to do that like my podcast
companies to reach out be like do you
want to be and i'd be like no and then
they asked again
and i was like no i can't stand her blah
blah because of the chris lee thing
and then they're like i don't know who
you think this is but this is like
whitney's assistant or something and it
was like someone directly from her camp
and then i felt really bad i didn't feel
bad because i thought it was my podcast
company just like ignoring somebody
like hi this is whitney cummings would
you like to come on the show you're like
no i hate that [ __ ]
yeah yeah oh no i felt and i felt so bad
and i i like apologize in video like i
know she probably does not give a [ __ ]
but her assistant was like a fan like
her just watch me
i'm sure oh no she i know she did
because her assistant was like
either a viewer i don't want to call him
like a family like a viewer or something
and i felt really bad and then
and then yeah like you said like you
just said now like a lot of times me
with shane too yeah like looking at
how long i was friends with shane is
like really gross like of course people
are gonna throw that in my face and i
i but i take it well this is gross
listen i get it
yeah yeah she's a good person she's a
good person yeah i literally don't know
her she's cool crystal
is not i'm gonna stop watching his
pocket they were done watching us i
watched the podcast to hate watch i like
to see him right you gotta stop hitting
your way watching everybody you're
getting you guys
love watching something it doesn't
feel good you do it's like you follow
the vlog squad you watch impulsive you
hate watch
uh congratulations it's like do you
watch anything for the enjoyment of it
i don't know how to explain it because i
feel like you don't know but like when
you've gone through like
uh i don't know how to explain it
there's this thing about like if you've
gone through a traumatic event right and
you're like scarred by these people
right so you keep up with them like just
to see
like i don't know how to explain people
have explained it before i'm like yes
that's exactly what i'm talking about
no i know what you mean you you i know
what you mean so consumed by them and
then like that's why
i there is a thing behind but you're
doing that to impulsive and chris dalia
impossible i don't hate watch i'm like
kind of a fan oh i think i tell you that
to make you feel better i can't do that
you tell me i say what are you doing you
watching a puzzle you say i hate watch
and then you say no i love them
like i can't deal with that i like logan
but i can't stand mike oh god it pissed
me off the last episode pissed me off
all right that's it this is not the
impulsive summary show
we gotta take a break i'm coming back to
this topic i have to come back to it
break and then we come back thank you to
upstart for sponsoring this episode
of frenemies when it comes to paying off
debt it can often feel like an uphill
battle
high interest rates resulting in minimum
monthly payments keeps you in an end the
cycle of debt
upstart can help you get ahead this is
good because you can rack up the debt
with all these credit cards and stuff
which i don't recommend i think you
should be responsible financially
keep those credit cards locked away
unless you go pay it off every month
you know what i'm saying but if you
messed up and you're becoming
responsible later in life
32 right i'm just saying it happens i
don't want people to give i mean
i validate consolidate what they do it's
not the present it's about the here and
the now
right mistakes happen mistakes happen
and upstart will consolidate your
all-in-one
loan so you don't have to worry about
high interest and they look at other
things besides your credit someone who
already has bad credit
if you're trying to get help with your
you know like paying off your debt they
look at your credit you're like i know i
have bad credit they also look at your
income
they look at other things which is
really great it's how people like get it
under control
let me tell you a little bit about
upstairs upstart is the first fact
oh i got the upstart is the fast and
easy way to pay off your debt with a
personal loan all online
whether it's paying off credit cards
consolidating high interest debt
or funding funding personal expenses
over half a million people have used
upstart
to get a simple fixed monthly payment
and you can receive funds as fast as one
business day after accepting your
loan which that's really fast you know
unlike other lenders
upstart looks at more you already said
that part yeah it's like
i skipped because i already said it they
look good she's right i'm just
co-signing basically it takes five
minutes online rate check and you got
all your debts consolidated into one
boom got him here's our call to action
so listen up you want to support the
show
find out how upstart can lower your
monthly payments day when you go to
upstart.com
frenemies that's upstart.com
frenemies and don't forget to use our
url to let them know we sent you
loan amounts will be determined based on
your credit income and certain other
information provided in your loan wait
you have to say that part really fast
because it's like the
you know on the radio when they go like
they're reloading i just have bad eyes
but i gotta get closer
yeah say this fast the whole thing or
just that part just that line loan once
will be determined based on your credit
income and certain other information
priority loan application go upstair.com
yeah yeah better if you do like find
yourself start and lower your monthly
payments today when you go to
upstart.com url to let them know that
you little money so we turn based on
your credit and comments
wait there's some parts i want them to
hear that's why i was doing it
i was just like the flying kid don't
mess with the tournament based on your
credit and come to certain other
information property but a little
application that was good
yeah it's hard to do yeah good job yeah
so hopefully you didn't hear that part
i'm kidding ethan get it together loan
amounts
i think they want people to know this is
loan amounts let's say really slow
really slow this is like the
let's say it really slow low an amount
will be determined
based on your credit income
and other information provided in your
loan
application application okay so if this
sounds like something you'd be
interested in go to
[Applause]
upstart.com
all right okay what okay
what were you saying okay i hate when
you do that throws me off
what did i do recounted we had to
restart when we restarted literally
just stretch my head off it does okay
it's
you always do this and then it's
confusing because people go the first
stick was like she's like oh i don't
want to talk about anymore i was like oh
what and then she was like
but we already took it and i was like
let's just redo it this is confusing and
now it's even more confusing
i have to be frank we should do it take
a look no no because that really will
mess me up like my mind gets like oh
if we do take three trista's just gonna
be like
when you do like starting restarting
something it literally makes me feel
like i
i would did something wrong and i'm
getting like punished or something i'm
like oh my god what did i do wrong like
that's what it feels like okay let me
just get my thoughts okay what is your
feelings on why
and why you keep bringing up impulsive
right now
into my house
let me just reiterate i love logan and i
hate mike and the other guy like i don't
like them at all because they're just
so hi they're just so and i hate to be
this person because i know i'm a girl
whatever that you know boys will be boys
like the bros you know like y'all
i hate guys like that because that is
exactly what they did they did they
basically reacted to the david dobrik
situation they're pre-filming a bunch
because logan's gone for four months so
they pre-filmed a bunch of stuff and now
it's coming out
a little bit behind how can you do
that's just that to me is like just
a big wow moment for me to know that
because it's like
you're doing a podcast on topical events
you're gonna post them four months
behind
i mean what is [ __ ] show i always
thought like if i got a broadway show
i would fly back once a week to do it
with you four seconds here now
talking now now well anyways now right
now you get to watch it tonight
they're a little bit behind on how can
you watch this it's upsetting it's like
an italian it's like
are you gonna put like uh it's like an
italian cooking with the
spaghetti it's just saying like it's a
pure dish it's like if you're gonna post
a four-month-old podcast as if it's new
content it's like putting uh
it's like putting uh american cheese and
a bowl of spaghetti and calling it
italian food come on
yeah yeah forget about it well anyways
so they were talking about the david and
obviously whatever and i was
i was just getting like triggered by it
because you know he was saying like
basically oh now all these people are
piling on all of a sudden on david like
out of nowhere and all this stuff like
seriously bro and i was like and he's
like i just understand now all of a
sudden like one person says something
and everyone else comes on and i was
like getting so mad because that's just
like this is the
people come out now i wanted to say this
people come out now because they feel
like
you know safe enough to do so that if
they say something their voice will be
heard as opposed before they follow you
said that logan
mike mike's a [ __ ] which made me piss
off because on
he went on some other i think it's
keemstar i don't know someone's podcast
and i don't know if it's his or her they
were a guest on it and he was basically
saying like
i guess if trisha paytas declares that
you're not a good person then
that's what you are about faze whoever
one of the faces were on there
and i was just like that's what i'm
saying these guys have like
zero like gravity and concept it's just
like when jason was like i'm gonna call
christian all this will be over it's
like this has nothing to do with like
just because i'm vocal about it like
doesn't mean it has anything to do with
me like there's actually people like
victims involved
and he was just like i don't like but
and then they kept trying to like code
it by saying like
oh well even not about david like but it
was clearly about david you know what
you can tell all the dudes sweating
right now about this
and being like oh oh they're the guys
who have skeletons in their club oh for
sure you're like oh
well i don't know if we we should be
canceling
he's like yeah dude you're [ __ ] next
because i can tell you're just a little
bit too anxious about this situation
when they try and be like and they they
said it without saying it right on
impulsive he was a little more attackful
without like saying my name like he did
on the other podcast
but it's like saying like well look at
the source like as if like
because i've had problems in my past
like saying i'm the source which i'm not
the first
but people say that like just because i
like raise awareness about one battle
oh it was face blinks his name's faze
banks by calling phase blanks because he
shoots blank dude i got no [ __ ]
brain he's got literally no brain so we
reacted to that too yeah he was saying
just look at the source
i was like okay let's [ __ ]
look at the sources when they come out
against you because you're a little too
anxious about this
the argument is so stupid even now when
i call people out like i'm like oh you
don't wear a mask and they're like well
you said the end were 10 years ago i'm
like okay
like i hate when people bring that stuff
up just because like that's the story of
my life
he had like other issues going on with
him and it's like just because like
something he did something bad doesn't
mean something bad can't happen to him
like you know what it's so cool yeah
it's because me and you are imperfect
people we can never um
we can never criticize anything as long
as we live because
one because we did something in our past
embarrassing 10 years ago i'll always
like i'll if something's happening now
like if something's happening to me now
i would
i'll like talk about it whatever but if
it's like it's something even whatever
so i'm confused i'm confused why we're
talking about impulsive kind of
um because mike's i don't and i don't i
don't hate watch it i love logan
okay he was grandpa monster on the math
singer
okay he wished me and my family he
wished my family and would die in a
[ __ ] uh
and a swat what did he wish upon me dad
do you remember
yeah it was the swatting he called me
scum of the earth yes
and he came through the internet
technically he said scum of this right
thank you dan we need to get our facts
straight
he called me skunk of the internet much
better right right
scum of the earth is kind of nicer
because it's like what's on earth like
monkeys
lions come with the internet it's like
um
i'll just come on the internet oh it's
coming the internet that's not as bad
he called me scum of the internet and
wished and wished that
i would get swatted instead of good
people like uh
what was it who's this i don't remember
yeah and his wish came true
so you supporting him is a personal i
take that okay i take it back
well it's too late you already knew that
and you keep watching his show and you
keep shouting him out
and i'm having a [ __ ] existential
practice watching it i mean the views
have gone so much down no one cares so
i'm you know
it's like a little sick puppy and you're
just like look at this little pup why
did our show will be a sick puppy and i
hope somebody will give us
it's gonna be a sick puppy if we don't
move on can i also say
okay uh
malik used to be fat that's all i wanted
to say okay oh really
and did you see that rachel bilson wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
you don't know the story no tell me tell
me
rachel bilson was best friends with
romney mouse in high school and she
posted a photo of them and he asked her
to take it down because he was fat in
the photo
that one right there it's okay to have
been fat it's
yeah he asked her to take it down okay
this was like a big scandal like last
week
so basically she's a little cubby yeah
from them in high school their best
friends high school
she's funny they go on a trip together
she posts all good things okay
so then rami malik dms her and asks her
to take the picture down
off the instagram and she like talked
about it then she goes yeah he like
asked me to take this picture
why because do you think and like but
why like your best friend's in high
school and she goes i thought he'd have
a good sense of humor about himself but
yeah i guess
that seems like a douche move especially
when she's like i love this person he's
like
i look a little chubby can you remove
your posts saying how great of a person
i am
i'd rather be known as skinny than nice
moon though once i lose the weight take
down all these episodes
[ __ ] i i i not exist fat i never
existed fat
but he's not even bad my sister said he
looks better there but honestly i think
he looks better now he doesn't look fat
he's just yeah he's because now he's
like really
but he's like he's this guy who's like
i'm just such a serious actor
is that it he's trying to be serious
such a serious actor and
i played for it i don't know i don't
like it um
he definitely would have gotten freddie
mercury looking like that so i guess
he's still like
he's not real neurotic he's like try
hard neurotic
you know yeah real neurotic is like
woody allen having sex with his own
daughter
that's neurotic that's real neurotic
i don't think rami malek would like me
uh i don't think
well no he clearly doesn't even like his
own friend from high school
well what do you like about you because
i have dreams that we were best friends
me and him
like during mr robot era and then no i
had these dreams that we were best
friends and then
then it comes out that he's the star of
the um what's the movie
the freddie mercury yeah that movie i
think i manifested that for him because
in our dreams he was using me for clout
you hear that rammy you owe trisha a
huge thank you i used to watch mr robot
before i'd go to bed and i would i would
dream that we weren't even dating it
wasn't even like that it wasn't like oh
we're dating whatever it was like we
were best friends and he's like trisha
like can you give me help and advice and
in my dreams i would give him this i'm
not kidding this
like literally like six months later
he's like the star of bohemian rhapsody
so he owes you big time and aren't in
short i'm not kidding but he's a douche
what do you want what do you want to do
with them
did you see that clip of him with the
fan the fan comes up to him with the
camera
and she's like she's like can you say hi
and he's like nope but i'll take a
picture have you seen that clip
i haven't but i agree i agree i i'm like
bishop this is like i don't like when
people turn me into a cameo
it same i i moses has been better at
saying no for
me oh it's been acting as your bodyguard
what do you say to people when they say
hey can we get a video what do you say
moses
like let's say you're at starbucks
you're clearly not busy
and a fan approached you says hey can i
get a video it happened yesterday at
target
so i tell them you know kavi she usually
she's usually in the car without the
mask already so i'm like well so you
stay in the car
and star power no people stalk the car
they'll just right okay let me set it up
so we come out from target
and if i know there's like people
waiting in the car
i look i don't run to my car if you come
and catch me i'll say hi
it's not that but here's my here's my
issue and i'll tell you the trigger
because this happened in target
yesterday too
in a separate incident people like laugh
right and maybe they're nervous whatever
but girls will be like oh my god say
something i'll pay you money if you just
say hi like just go up to her like that
and it's like they're laughing and going
in high school so
my trauma is like oh they're like they
might be making fun of me or something
yeah yeah
yeah and it happens because people will
be like you know like and
those kind of kids irritate the [ __ ] out
of me so i heard them there's people
doing it like
go i'll give you ten dollars just go
just just and then they shout
like and then they go like this and i'm
like [ __ ] you like i hate those kind of
people so i was already on edge right
so now we drove my pink car which
normally we don't do we usually take his
pickup truck because i don't like people
they know the car so they're stocking
the car so like there was a group of
girls in this car
and again i don't run we put the bags
away or whatever and then as soon as i
hear them like snickering i'm like i'm
gonna go in the car like those are
i don't know if they're being haters or
whatever the bad ones yeah so i'm like
i'm gonna go in the car and then of
course
i'm sitting in there moses is like
loading the things and they come up and
this one girl's like giggling actually
coming up to moses like
are you are you moises and i mean
granted granted
she's spanish so that's maybe the
spanish name for him i don't know
but and he's like yes and then um
what did she say to you what's the word
do you remember oh is trisha in the car
ready
any chance i could take a picture with
her i was like well she's in the car oh
that's that's presumably people get
really pretty waiting for us they were
there when we got there like yeah
yeah they could have seen like they saw
us coming like again i will take
even if you're being [ __ ] and
giggling but i would love to see a photo
of you behind a really tinted window
being like
i've definitely done that before you
remember the jewish kids here in um
in this area so you live in like this
really posh area where we're at now when
we go get starbucks right and i sit in
the car for stop because i don't want my
mask on or whatever
and so one time moses went in this was
like last week i think and there was
these like
jewish like one jewish boy came to my
car and i was like not a math and i'm
like there's a reason i'm saying they're
jewish i'm not just like trying to
signal them out or whatever like that
but i was like oh man and these are like
straight guys right how did you know
they were jewish trisha
because they listen they told me they
ended up telling me because so anyways
because they spoke hebrew whatever and
so so i was like
mask like i can't like i'm just doing
that weird stuff because it's a straight
guy right and straight guys i just know
are like making fun of me or some stupid
because it happened remember that kid
that flicked me off
he's like david's amazing and like
flicked me off it was crazy she's like
oh you got a david hater yeah
like my yeah the sister's like say hi to
my brother
that is crazy anyways whenever a
straight guy comes up to me i'm like oh
whoa okay let me just shorten up the
story because i know we have a lot to do
so then anyways so i was like okay but
then
so he's like okay no worries whatever
then two more jewish guys like straight
young jew guys come up to me they look
like juke crazy not even joking they
kind of had that vibe to them and i was
like oh
so they're coming up to me while i'm
sitting in the car like now there's
three people i'm gonna look like an
[ __ ] because they're filming me i'm
like
let me get my freaking mask on even
though i'm sitting in the car for the
reason not to wear my mask i get up
and they were just being an actress
moses out of nowhere comes running
because he was in getting starbucks i'm
like what the hell like he came because
he's like on it to protect me and he's
like right there whatever
and then they're like you're you're the
jew or something right what did they say
to you
something in hebrew like hi you know we
said no but they called you a jew
they're like you're the jew
boyfriend or something yeah they said
something weird like that and i was like
what the [ __ ]
well then they were also like trying to
speak hebrew
right that's what oh right yeah there
were anyways it was probably
yeah and then there was guys and there
was like four of them
anyways so moses's go-to now is just to
be like coveted whatever but he's good
anyways he probably
say listen we don't okay whatever no
videos if there's
i have to someone asked me seven
different times in a target she came up
to me seven different times started
saying hi to people and i was like
i can't do this anymore and i like i do
lose my [ __ ] sometimes honestly like
seven times seven seven did she not come
up seven separately i said no and she
kept coming back no i said yes the first
time say hi to karen okay say hi to me
all right all right i'd be like all
right well you know
i don't have a cameo but that's gonna be
about 500 dollars per video
yeah i said listen i don't want to do a
video but i'll take a photo it went
viral though because she was already
filming so then it went viral people
like rob
romney's such a like [ __ ] what i mean
you can't understand how annoying it is
to be on public and like a photo is one
thing but when people start taking a
video it's like
this presumption that you owe them this
time it's like a photo is one thing like
snap
saying hi is if one thing like hi how
are you nice to meet you thanks for
watching
the videos like say hi to my sister i
mean what like now i'm in a conversation
with somebody on the phone i mean
i have to say hello and goodbye you have
to think of something it's a [ __ ]
house
making fun of me like sometimes i'll say
hi to someone and i see that on
tick-tock being like oh my god look at
her she's a [ __ ] loser doing a cameo
like they like say it's like
it's not a cameo anyways i i say no
videos no videos
anyway he's in love peace and love
circle alive
don't ask moses too like ask me if
you're gonna ask ask me because moses is
gonna be my
my nosh it's covered well why do you
want people to ask you then
because then i'll say okay like i don't
like when people ask permission like
from from moses like
like you saw me walk come ask me i don't
know i think it's a little like [ __ ] oh
okay
yeah i don't know yet
i love you i know you probably don't
like me but hey if you want to come in
front of me there's an open seat here
veto we have a look alike maybe we can
get um a b in when he comes
vetoing that welcome i wasn't included
in that the h3 look alike
hello oh i don't know why i didn't make
the meme you do look like aziz ansari
yeah thank you you know um
that's so crazy um
oh we had a soundbite competition you
were in the finalists the [ __ ] you dan
first uh shout out to the fans i heard i
tried to watch it was four hours
yeah it's funny so stupid so by the way
here i wa before why did you go four
hours
we had a lot to talk about what do you
want well people like there's a lot of
show i'm out here i'm doing my thing
i'm getting i'm doing a service for the
people where's our enemies are we over
nfts i was like so excited about now
they're not ready they'll be here next
week can we do a live auction
sure trisha you you
yeah wow imagine how i feel every time
you bring up impulsive
it's unfucking believable yeah well at
least my story's good
my story is actually good i'm like yours
about impulsive
i don't even know where i was going
sometimes i don't know where i'm going
on these stories today okay well listen
you always talk about how you don't
think the foot army the wiki feet
foot soldiers thing is funny here's
proof that it's funny
proof [ __ ] literal irrefutable proof
i made a discovery last week i thought
oh i'm not on wiki feet
and i it was kind of nice because like i
didn't have to see
what people thought of my feet right but
i've been known you're on i didn't know
there was a separation from wikifeet
and wikifeet men where like men have
their own website
and you know what when i went and
googled myself the other day
to see if i was on wiki feet i was
highly offended to find
that i have a one star rating come on
do you got to admit that's awesome
that's foot soldier army
how do you know it's you you're who do
you think's giving him one stars out
that we run this [ __ ]
maybe rylan has ugly feet i'm [ __ ]
keen holy [ __ ] on wiki feet
and you know what i have some great feet
photos on
here about it too that's what shows your
nation
tell me that's not funny i dare you
right now i don't think it's your people
how do you know it's your people doing
it
my god you can't give me credit for
anything dude it's obviously footnation
who do you think find you on wikifee i
went on i think it's like wikipedia or
something i'm number one it's easy to
find
the men thing yeah it's on the man um
bro you literally can't acknowledge how
funny that is that he went to wiki feet
no looked himself up and he had one star
he had one star of all your gigs that's
the least funny that's like vape
nation's funnier than that
dude i'm telling you this friendship
sometimes feels uneven
like i ride for you so hard especially
when it comes to like rylan
i've literally gone out of my way and
tanked the wiki feed on violence
and meanwhile you coming here talking up
logan paul who literally wants to
kill my whole family and my dogs who
wants to assassinate
me and you're coming here talking about
like i just said why why don't i get the
same response
logan paul i denounce him now no you
don't you don't keep watching
it now you've you've already denounced
him and then came back and said you
loved him
so whatever this is the final this is
the final i
will never talk i will never even watch
impulsive i don't believe you i just
they're my motivation to work out he's
so buff
i want to look like there's lots of buff
and people in the world
people say they watch our podcast with
food yeah so that
so impulsive you watch we've got more
we've got more people there's probably
way more fat people in the united states
than
first of all hello shout out to our fans
people with eating disorders they don't
feel as bad if when we're eating like we
should eat more on the show because they
feel more comforted i know you can't now
because you're on a diet but when
i hope that we have more to offer the
world than just eating being fat orange
chicken we had that one time we should
eat that on camera because that was
so good okay okay that's the best
chicken i've had i
love worn chicken i have more chicken
and pan express i've made orange chicken
okay good that's nice we should do that
when you're when you're
comfortable again when you're i just
need a couple weeks yeah detox maybe but
then i'm down i'm on the orange chicken
train
um okay before we move on free it's
protein well it's deep fried
and bread and like crazy sugary sauce
but you don't eat the rice
no orange chicken is not is terribly
unhealthy just to be
just to be straight up can i talk about
one other thing or do you have something
else one time
one more thing i gotta bring up anyone
okay i do have one more thing here but
you can go ahead and uh
the bad baby thing i am so like okay i'm
glad like good for her
bad baby made a million dollars in like
60. the only fancy
i think it's disgusting if you signed up
for it you guys are disgusting like
a freshly turned 18 year old like just
you're like waiting for her to turn 18
and show the nudes i think that's so
gross she's like you all been asking for
it i turned 18.
two days exhausting at first i thought
she like made it before she turned 18
but i was like oh thank god
if you're signing up for bad babies only
fans and that's no hate to her because
she's young or whatever but you're
you're a piece of [ __ ] you're disgusting
she's she's still a teenager you're
nasty like you're disgusting dude the
crazy thing about bad baby is like i've
always thought she's way older like when
i first saw her i was like
i looked up and i was like she's 14 you
know what i mean
not not i was just just i feel bad
because here's my thing right i support
sex workers 100
it's just like my stance is this and i
still say it like wait till you're like
25 to know that you really want to do
sex work i
like you're still young at 25 you still
can look 18 at 25 whatever
but like you may regret it 18 years old
it's good advice
because like i know people who did porn
at like 18
the problem is that you pro like there's
this really uh vulnerable age between
like
18 and you know 25 where you really need
to make money and you don't know what to
do with your life you know what i mean
okay but i don't think she's in that
position i'm not judging her i'm just
saying no no no no i'm trained i'm just
telling 18 25 year olds
there's there was another young girl 23
that got hot in this like situation and
i felt
bad for her everyone was kind of
attacking her but i felt bad for her
because at 23
you don't know i don't even know if
she's nude it might just be like the
like the
bikini pick kind of thing that i've seen
other girls i don't know i haven't seen
it yet but if you're if you're under the
age of 25 don't you only i agree though
it's
it's amazing how many thirsty [ __ ]
signed up for that [ __ ] like
holy [ __ ] if you're like lusting after
like a newly turned 18 year old you're
gross
yeah there's plenty 21 year olds that
look 18 like just go for them like
there's a whole porn category i mean
james charles got a whole
probably ruined the whole guidebook no
he hasn't followed it but he's got the
guidebook
how did it date the oldest youngest
looking person possible
by james charles james also makes me
want to puke um okay let me get on
because i have
i have a few more things to get to that
we need to talk about before we get to
wor world war ii doing the same mistake
we're running out of time
dan how long we've been going about 50
minutes [ __ ]
we have 10 minutes to talk about this or
we're not going to get i was just going
to say i feel
i was frustrated that we can't stay on
track but i thought you were faking your
trust because
no i don't do okay here you posted let's
focus
we're not i'm not going to get derailed
you posting memes now
well this is what we have to save money
for our same time for oh full screen
right sorry
[ __ ] idiot oh my god this is not that
so you go i told you i'm not sleeping
you stupid frog do you know what this
meme is
this is the evil kermit mean right and
you know and then so like a good
okay so good i don't know what the
caption means though
the captions that kind of just went uh
because agent i just kind of went like
free agent yeah because
i guess a good a proper meme would be
like me gets in bed at 9 00 p.m
also me stays up till 4am watching
netflix oh yeah i saw those but i didn't
like those
okay that's funny don't you think mine
was funny it didn't really make sense
but i like that you're trying next up we
have another meme
this one squinting lady i like this girl
squinting ladies
is classic i like her okay i see you
again again very very literal but
literally
funny last time i was on here he's like
that's literal it's funny okay i see you
i mean okay okay what would your caption
be well
the thing is like you can't just make a
me like the memes need to be frustrated
so if everyone's just like okay i see
you like that's the literal okay so
what's the meme take on it it's like me
it's like me
seeing the it's like me looking me
looking for
the uh sexual partners of james charles
over 25.
ah right because the whole thing is like
she's
she's looking carefully oh like you're
trying really hard to find yes yes
i was going the same route thank you dan
okay
something like that would be appropriate
not bad and then uh
me trying to me trying to find me seeing
15
and whatever dan stole my joke sorry
me trying to spot uh someone over eight
yeah
[ __ ] and this is one you posted this
one's for you
this one got the most likes of all of
them
jewish that's yeah i was thinking of you
and that mean that you showed me on the
show can you explain this one because i
didn't get it you showed me the meme on
the show
you are jewish we had passover that was
so she's trying is the lady trying to
figure something no that's your meme you
showed me on the show
and you are jewish so it's a meme so
it's a whole little story
we looked at this meme together and i'm
jewish if you know you know right
wow that's what people know in the
comments and that's why it has the most
likes because they knew they watched
frenemies
i think they were just shocked by how
odd it was
jewish i thought it was funny it's very
meta it was for you
thank you i didn't understand oh and
then here's an actual meme that crushed
on our
oh this was a meme that i actually
thought was great and thank you so much
for saying it
you tweeted at me uh and you said h3
productions that's me
best friend memes yeah now that's a good
meme
thank you that's [ __ ] awesome just
taking a photo yeah a screenshot of your
phone
i was trying to find one that pertained
to us but i didn't get them so i didn't
know what was like offensive what i did
let me just
oh and then there's another one just
since we're into they made a trisha
doing the math meme wow i said trisha
trying to figure out how to send me a
meme
wait you posted this yeah in response to
yours i didn't see
so wow there you are you've been
uh you're in the meme verse
i can't close this window okay there it
is i like it thank you so much
i'm done with the meme though please
stop me meaning me well
i don't know it doesn't work like that
here here's one that got a lot of
likes on the subreddit trisha meme
living an extra 10 years
no dying with a belly full of nuggets
yes i mean they just
took what i said on the show not really
it's based on the drake name i made that
meme i know
they're paying homage to your great joke
okay so it's not meme they're just joke
stealers
that's most of me to be honest
they're paying amish to you look at they
love you
and here you are calling them joke
thieves
well okay james charles update before we
get started i'm going to
move it on out of now just a quick james
charles update
since um his apology there has been a
total get ready drumroll please
15 boys in total have made allegations
against james for sending an appropriate
message
and nine of them are miners
congratulations james charles those are
major league numbers right there boy
nine miners have come forward with
receipts against james charles
that boy is in the hall of fame it's
mind-blowing he's right
he's right up there with like barry
bonds you know
mark maguire you remember when he broke
that home run record that's james
charles
it's just like all the people liking his
photo the video too
like all the likes and support now it's
like well just goes to show
how i think if anything it just goes to
show how his young fans don't
his fans are young because anyone with a
[ __ ] brain right
who's over 18 right yeah there's nobody
over 18 that still supports james right
that's impossible pewdiepie he defended
james from the tati video he defended
oh that's old he was collab with um
james charles that unsettled me but it
was filmed before
like the controversy blob i think but he
has something to say about everybody he
doesn't have anything to say about this
considering he just collapsed with him
maybe she should be like ah i don't
support this [ __ ] i
have not caught up with pewdiepie so i
can't say
definitively if he has or has not said
anything he hasn't i haven't
i watch him i keep up with him
do you watch everybody how much how much
people do you watch
well i do a lot of working out i'm
always on the elliptical and i watch
people
isn't he just like usually making
minecraft videos and [ __ ] like yeah but
like listen to him talk because i always
think like oh maybe he's going to
mention some team
i see i used to never watch him i didn't
give an
f about him well anyways so nine miners
folks
nine miners so shout out to james what
was that thing
what's that what'd you just close out uh
it was robbie malik
what is that oh i had i was trying to
find the
bra i was trying to find that
we were talking about it earlier i was
trying to find the fat picture you were
talking about
we already showed it okay okay i know
this is from forever guys i'm trying
so hard to keep this show on this show
so i know but
somebody's got to keep it on the rails
maybe i want to go on the ramey malak
rail
we already been on the rummy relic rail
how many times from a longer you want to
talk about romney malek you dream about
roman value you talking about romney
malik you're [ __ ] obsessed are you
watching
dude this whole life is about romney a b
looks like romney alec
you want to have him on a guest really
yes okay
done what if he did that's so meta
i'd be like i remember when you're fat
you can't hide from me you would be
yeah okay okay and then oh and then just
a shout out to
more morphe right yeah i can't believe
it's morphe that just didn't seem right
i thought it was morph
morphe like morphe is just like
i like morph better yeah i don't really
get that because morph is like
morphine morpheus cosmetics they support
trash people
and your product sucks it's overpriced
and it caused me to break out
morphy you suck keep supporting jeffree
star james charles and all these other
well
morphy um is still promoting james
products despite
uh james confessing to
having inappropriate contact with two
miners and six confessing
to actual miners here's their post
saying oh his pigment is poppin
they dropped shade morphs quickly and
they said x james charles palette
let's go look at him popping off the
screen oh wow look at him popping off
the screen he could almost pass says 18
folks there's a 16 year old he could
almost pass the 16. let's get him in
with this is a good promo to get into
the dms of james charles folks brought
to you by morphe
palace and noah back saying oh he can
bounce back from this you don't bounce
back from being an
actual p word i hate morphy i hate
morphy
so much like besides having a [ __ ]
product you're just [ __ ]
people that you're supporting this like
because of this this is why james keeps
going and keeps driving because he has
morphe like paying his bills he doesn't
need anything else oh yeah
he has like more declining his pockets
and you guys are disgusting and gross
i mean he admitted to it it's not even
like let's stop with the you know
allegation it's not allegations he
admitted to it it's a crime that's it
like we talked about it because it
happened and we both talked about it
individually so it's like
i didn't want to talk about individuals
but like yeah he was like uh he's like
yeah i did it
he's like yeah i did it i'm sorry did
you talk just a bit there was a youtuber
that went to prison for 10 years who's
in prison
i don't know if you want to i know we
have to do the satisfying what i want to
do we're almost done we've almost got
there we've almost made it through
this youtuber austin jones interestingly
i didn't know about this you told me
about it
austin jones is a former musician who
was active on youtube from 2077
2017 wow 10 years he's an old-school one
prior to his arrest for production of
child p-word in 2017
he was at so he was asking underage
girls to twerk for
him he had to apologize we're so sorry
you know sound familiar james was like
look i'm sorry what can i we're gonna
work through this we're all together
gonna work through this
well this guy austin jones is in prison
currently
serving a 10-year sentence in federal
prison
um shout out to his he was asking for
underage girls james is asking android
guys and i really do think there is like
once again
that sort of mentality where we always
talk about it where it's like if it's
happening to guys it's like not as
serious as if it's happening to girls
well clearly i feel like if this was
girls would be like on fox news with
tucker
and fox news went to prison james
charles
it would be like this whole if it was
young girls would be tucker cars and be
like
our girls are under under attack by but
oh well it wouldn't be
like uh youtube is destroying our
culture and our young girls are under
attack and this predator is online to be
like a whole
media frenzy about it but then it's like
oh
you know it's crazy it's so fun that's
like the most frustrating thing it's so
frustrating it's so frustrating
well anyways he's promoted he's like
getting dropped like
we love james i can't so i wanted to ask
you actually do you think he's gonna be
totally fine coming out of this
it's hard to tell like long-term no but
maybe like short-term yeah but like
it'll happen it's just like with anybody
after a certain amount of time and
it does catch up to them because because
you know what like these people who are
sick like this they keep doing it normal
people be like i got caught not gonna do
it again
but sick people like can't help
themselves but do it again he's sick
because he's apologized
he's been accused of this he's been
given eli made this great point where we
talked about it on friday
she's like he's already got his second
chance right and now he's back here
apologizing for having done it like what
now we know like 15 times like
chances the top thing like all of that
yeah so i think now that people are
i think he's gonna keep making videos
but now he's not i think all these mega
celebs and brands are not gonna
want to associate with him so i mean i
guess that's like
getting closer to like getting him help
because he's like literally sick and
he'll keep doing it and like these
you know 16 year olds will it's just so
this is so gross well anyway i
analyzed the whole [ __ ] video on
friday at uh painful detail
so if you want to watch that that's
there but it's four hours long
don't well you got time to watch
everybody's [ __ ] content on youtube
i watched it you watched all of it no
you did it i did
i did i tried to be cool like i watched
it
i did i had benny hannah my belly was
full i was like you washed all four
hours yeah i had my blanket
so this was his mom he came home at
chocolate so we watched the end of it
you were still going with mother's day
aren't you excited that you were in the
final round of the sound bite battle
i was but you guys were kind of [ __ ]
on me being like um we should put her in
the same category
why do you pretend like you weren't
watching i don't know i tried to be cool
it's not cool it hurts my feelings oh
really
i don't want to be like a noob and be
like okay so the last history podcast
was really good
you know what i mean i don't want to be
that prison yeah but you're also kind of
like you don't have to be like i watch
everything
but like you're like i want literally no
i watch everything because i watch it oh
okay okay okay
well thank you i'm glad well my fear was
going to be tricia to church a head off
and it would be like i don't like that
though and then you guys were like oh
thank god like
it was no it was love to you it was just
that
it wasn't left to me it really was i had
two categories that were killing it and
you guys were like we should just put it
as one we messed up and i was just we
should have i mean
they were why because i killed all the
other ones obviously my songs were
better than half the sounds you guys
chose
so you're welcome well didn't win and
then
because you guys were pushing so hard
like oh not trisha no this one has to
win so of course people are gonna be
like okay
you never had a chance against shout
outs
well it one-handedly it beat everybody
it even be
the semen is a ton of type of milk
it well too long if i'm being honest
yeah yeah yeah it went it went while we
were having some technical issues we
kept scratching strawball
anyway we actually made it through
everything we wanted to talk about
hi and so how much time do we have left
uh let's so let's just get started
i like the h3 i just watch it if you
talk about me i like it when you talk
about me on it thank you you're like
trisha had a good take and i'm like oh
thank you i get excited yeah i gave you
so i gave you lots of love i even showed
one of your tweets i was like trisha was
on point on fire with this slam dunk
broke about like you're a celebrity when
i'm watching you on tv and i'm like oh
my god a celebrity is talking about me
oh really that's good yeah um we we have
uh
plenty of time for this segment hold on
hold on before we
move on i i know that there will be a
lot of comments uh
saying why didn't you guys talk about
this if we don't
did both of you see the fact the snl
sketch about david dobrik oh yeah
i mean it was it was good what are you
saying like that oh you're so rick
you're like
well it was fine it was funny i mean i
just thought it was a trip that they
made an snl school about no that's so
true all tweets were like finally a
sketch not written by 75 year olds like
they were relevant they were like
current
and i love okay i hate kyle mooney but i
like love him but i
hate him why do you hate him because
he's from youtube i was like oh he gets
it but it was funny
i feel like it wasn't enough about david
dobrik to be like a total diss on him
it totally was it was just like youtuber
apology culture jp's
jp pranked next week they totally had
the kissing prank they had the black
hoodie they had these
apologies i think so yeah and what was
the name it wasn't it was like a play on
vlog squad it was like the
yeah you're the prank prank
and then they had the second apology he
goes hey guys a lot of you said my first
apology wasn't sincere but now it is
because now i'm on the floor like he was
definitely like oh wow it's very
specific
no i watched it i thought it was funny
kai mooney drives me not so but like
probably a fan of the show if anyone is
we could probably land kyle mooney and
here you are talk [ __ ] our one fan
no you know he's that type that thinks
he's real like cool because he's like a
writer on snl and he's jewish
oh you don't make any sense get your
[ __ ]
now you're being all anti-semitic
there's one sketch okay and then we can
go i promise but there is one sketch
that is so you know i watch it every day
and i hate it so much
it gives me so much rage and i can't
stop it watching i watch it every day
every day it's with gal gadot kyle
mooney and who's the other guy that's
his partner i forget his name
someone else and it's the girl like the
last fry have you seen that sketch
it's so it literally makes me want to
scratch my eyeballs out it is
so awful i feel that way about most the
sketches on that show to be honest
really i can't watch it it's just it's
so fun like
like sometimes they hit it's but but
mostly there's so many that are so bad
that it's like it makes me want to
physically [ __ ] die
and frankly i'm not even going to blame
it in the comedians on the show because
it's so hard to
blame him no i'm not going to do that
because it's so hard even when you go
back to like the apparent golden days of
snl it's the same you know that's not
true it is true
it's so hard to make sketch comedy every
[ __ ] week like that
that half of it is going to be dog ship
just by the very nature of it king tut
originated on snl
king tut i think that [ __ ] is so [ __ ]
good but
it's so dumb this is why they're gonna
ask me to host and not you so bye
oh really i don't know oh really when i
host i'm not going to even mention
vietnamese i'm not going to even give a
shout out they're going to be like you
might know yeah you'll probably give a
shout out to impulsive
yeah shout out to my best friend
shout out to my best friend logan paul
in his as impulsive i love him
i even thought about wearing like teddy
fresh on the show i'm not gonna even do
it on my monologue now i'm gonna come
out
and i'm not gonna wear i'm gonna wear
maverick clothing that's what i'm gonna
wear all mapped out
i did think about wearing teddy fresh
for you but i was like no not anymore
okay
in your big fantasy well you're not
going to get any [ __ ] talking and being
ended calling
would you call him a jew i'm a you said
we're jews at the beginning of the show
he said
no i very clearly made the distinction
that not you
i said us as in like the against on the
proverbial
side of the table i'm not discriminating
about something you're not
oh my god you got to check yourself
i love this sketch i thought it was like
really i thought it was really
interesting that it became mainstream
and noted as other people have noted
that david doberg's dream was to be on
snl like he's always talked about that
that was like his life
and he made it yeah that is that's
brutal i didn't know that but that's
he was working towards it you know oh
everyone was like this is our generation
jimmy fallon which i never really got
that comparison anyways because like
he's not a toxic
host but well he wanted to be yeah no
that was his goal to me
my my nightmare job would be a talk show
host it's like you have to sit there and
flatter celebrities and
get it stand there and care it's like i
don't [ __ ] care about once some
and then like they're not even like most
of the times they're not even famous
they're like from some really obscure
[ __ ]
shitty cop show that you don't give it's
like wow what was that like
oh oh tell me about that spirit you had
looked like
like everything's so [ __ ] funny it's
so fake i
would die before i became a talk show
host thank you
i'll become a talk thank you for my
coming to my ted talks fine
all right we'll be ryan and kelly and
i'll be just kelly also i'd rather die
than go on saturday night live
cause it just seems like a lot of work
not because i'm opposed it just seems
like a lot okay
lazy i just it's like i'll take it i'll
be on it
yeah you're not you're if you go on if
you go on saturday night live
i will what's something really valuable
i could put on the line
like what
i'll cut my arm off my whole arm i don't
put your arm on
jesus if you go on snl
that's a threat if you go on snl i'll
cut my [ __ ] arm off
oh my god he's so dark
let's do this obviously i don't want
moony writing for me though you're not
getting [ __ ] because now he's a
superstar with that sketch
everybody's shouting out his name i love
kyle mooney he's awesome
at jewish brothers we we dogs don't
listen to this [ __ ]
fake phony ass jew dogs for life jews
ride
hebrew hammer [ __ ] let's go all right
next
we are back and we are on the rails
officially
we are on to the segment part i don't
like that you get to conduct this train
but okay
okay all right today we are doing
we're doing satisfying can they see that
camera with their arms in the shop
because look how fat my arm compared to
yours go like this
flex it flex it no flex your arm oh my
god look at your forearm how skinny you
are
and your bicep oh my god you're so
skinny next to me i have huge forearms
so they look like popeyes
anyways okay you're off the rails today
today
we are doing oddly satisfying i will
take the butcher knife you can get the
dental tools
and we are going to what the [ __ ] can i
ask what is this i find this
so disturbing and weird turns off the
soap yolks you like
what is the purpose of this thing it's
meant for carving clay
oh okay that makes sense carving clay
yeah like sculpting um yeah so we're
gonna carve soap
okay so what i have no idea what we're
doing ian is conducting this ian
uh yeah so the first one is uh uh soap
cutting
kind of shaving it making lines it's
supposed to relax me and make me feel
oddly satisfied
with the audience right yeah everyone's
supposed to be relaxed now
everyone relax which soap should i do
let's do dial
you got this because you're the cheapest
bro
we got lush bruh we got this expensive
yeah there's some fancy soaps there oh
yeah okay lush
okay so we're gonna do we're just gonna
shave some dial here we go everybody
here we go everybody relax now you got
to be quiet though
relax do we have zen music
relax relax
that is fun oh my gosh get a good streak
going it's like peeling
off the skin on my meanwhile there's
like kids in africa who could be washing
with the soap
we can donate
oh wait we'll gather up the shavings and
ship it off to africa oh here's our
here's our soap shavings this is nice
though
is that relaxing you yeah it's kind of
nice
can you imagine just sitting alone in
your office and just shaving stuff like
i'd be like there's something wrong with
this
i love it but you know what i mean yeah
oh baby it's like face peeling oh my god
why did you say that that was so weird
oh i'm so relaxed this style soap is
doing something to me wow these are nice
when you get that long piece it's like
getting
peeling off sunburn let's see who can
take the longest piece let's do this
into a competition
all right well i've already been going
on the back but okay okay ready here we
go long piece challenge
got it all the way down thank you
sorry wait let me see that fat piece of
yours oh my god
oh i just broke it okay let me do it not
that big i can do oh my god relax that's
pretty fat
you beat that loser relax oh my god okay
fine i didn't know we're going for the
fatty
award i thought we're going for the
longest no it's longest
it doesn't matter how fat it is well you
just said fat
ah i mean that one's that's a that's a
world record
i come on we got a good one okay i think
trisha's first was probably the winner
but well now i never know yeah all right
because it's no because
now it's not even oh man all right
oh thank you ian oh chalk sounds like i
hate shock
i'll do it i hate everything about chalk
which cut you have a color preference
here
we hate everything about chalk i hate
the sound i hate the feeling i don't
like
anything about chalk it makes me very
uncomfortable does theodore play with
chalk yes and i try to
draw with him on the concrete and it
just i i do it because i love theodore
obviously but like
it's torment do you ever wonder how he
turned out so cute
well his mom you think it's all
well yeah that's true i guess i feel
like our baby will turn out super cute
because oh that's kind of nice
it's not like a chalky sensation it is
kind of nice guys ready for this
oh it kind of like here let me give you
some asmr here instead of mike
is this the worst segment i like how it
just kind of
bursts yeah that's nice look at that so
much
i feel like relax everybody relax
relax
[Applause]
stupid why didn't you get the blast
trying to relax why are you calling me
stupid
ah because that aesthetic would have
been so nice go black
dare you you know the mental hospital
they give you crayons but not with the
wrappers on them because they don't want
you to choke on the wrapper
they think you'll kill yourself by
swallowing the rabbit rapper isn't that
friend
yeah well you could choke on the cringe
dude when i was in the point maybe
that's not why they do it i was in fifth
grade i [ __ ] you not
a kid shoved a crayon up his nose so far
he started bleeding out of his nose and
he couldn't get it out and a hospital
and an ambulance had to come so you
won't talk about
rapper danger no the crayon itself is a
threat
neutralize it do you do that on a dare
or something no he's just [ __ ]
like just put a crayon up his nose
nobody dared him i put a candle stick
with my ass one time
yeah you mentioned that a lot trisha oh
well i was just trying to compete with
that story
why do you mention that is that like
that's the only thing i've had traumatic
happen to me i was trying to think of
another hospitalization
give me the context of the candle story
because you mentioned it all the time so
i went through i was just really high
and i was like escorting
and the guy your client wanted to put a
candlestick up here yeah
i was like kind of chubby but like
chubbier than the other escorts so i was
just like the girl i would do anything
so i'm like you want to do something
[ __ ] get trish
your name was your escort name was ten
t-e-m
oh t-e-m t-e-n ten oh like number ten
circle but i would tell people i'm from
tennessee i'm like oh i'm tanks i'm from
tennessee
oh you got a candlestick up your ass
circle alive
oh cause it was a circle on the bottom
that's crazy
all right what's next
yes
thank you thank you with peace and love
this is amazing i need to start hiring
like someone to help me out in life
like this just like this would be so
much easier to have someone to help me
in general isn't that what moses is for
oh yeah but i need to do find someone i
can pay to do it so i feel like not
guilty about it like i feel guilty that
he helps me so much so i need to find
someone that i can like
hey it's hard man it's hard to find good
people can you guys email me if you have
a resume
i need to find my own group of people
you have your h3 boys i need like
i don't know what you mean your tricials
like skittles trish
tricials oh okay animal girls
candlestick girls
i like go ahead what's next uh so this
is called kinetic sand
oh you uh oh this thing kind of smush it
mash it
cut it i do this with uh theodore so
okay
i'm kind of an expert already i'm just
saying i'm familiar with kinetic and it
is cool
i am not a [ __ ] two-year-old so this
[ __ ] is a little
like cool i'm two years old i'm playing
with kinetic sand dope
wow cool epic
you're doing it wrong smells kind of
good
no it doesn't what is the
point of this it's just it's it's sand
that sticks together so it is really
cool like theodore loves it
because he loves playing with sand but
unlike normal sand
it like acts almost like a
like a clay it's re it's cool i like it
it is cool yes theodore loves it
what kind of [ __ ] insane chemicals is
this made out of yeah that's what i
wonder too
because i've played with something that
is really syrupy and sticky and i'm like
oh boy
you gotta squeeze it between your
fingers like this but you can you can
make it into like a ball
and then it just like drips
kind of interesting part of it don't you
don't tell me how to be satisfied
are you calling with that no who says
look at you you're mushing they're like
no this is what you do
pull your mic in front of you okay you
didn't have your mic in front of you
the beginning this episode you're like i
don't want to be mean to you now you're
like wow you don't have a microphone
yeah well
you spend your whole [ __ ] episode
talking about logan paul and ramy malik
stupid you're such a hater
okay i got a big-ass ball and now i'm
gonna put it on the knife
and see what happens oh look at me i
think i found something
i think i found something all day
satisfying you're just letting gravity
cut yeah
oh that's [ __ ] sad i think i just
discovered something
i think you did that was nice
and i see trisha's on the level of
theodore my two-year-old
just and i'm here innovating and you're
just smashing
it what did you do let it drop
innovated you're going to see this on
tick tock whether you've got a bajillion
views
here you want to see it again slow-mo no
nobody wants to see it i'm kind of over
this one to be honest i mean i love
peace and love but this one i'm over
wait well wait no no oh
god it wasn't that great honestly yeah
step in front of it
please one more time for everyone who
got wrong somebody care
oh my god oh my god
sorry ian thank you i do like that i
don't think dan likes it
we have a fan oh what is this i like
this this i like
all right so whoa it's cold and wet this
one's called floral foam
you slice it chlorofoam you sniff it and
pass out
not chloroform floral foam floral so you
cut off
little slices of it little pieces kind
of slow cut it
you have a knife to your left too me
oh no ethan you have one over there
trying to come for my knife
this turned into a way different show oh
my god it's scary
i get triggered like a samurai sword
like a little is that our thumbnail
oh that's a good idea so you cut pieces
and then
uh over the tin you can kind of squeeze
it and water comes out
how thick do we do it as thick as you
want it mommy mommy daddy like
the chlorofoam what is the purpose of
this
well i think it's for gardening
what is the purpose of this i use it to
make fl
uh flower arrangements why
it holds the stem inside of it you like
you jam the stem into it and then i
think because it's uh
it's incredible how many pro like people
just made a product for that
it feels good though i do like it but i
think it keeps the flowers fresh because
it's
there's water in it right so it's able
to like genius dude i kind of want to
just go for the whole thing
yeah i think it feels so good oh yeah i
want to do that
i love that you guys you have to feel it
but wow that is a nice
oh look it doesn't look satisfying it
looks ugly it's
juicy that's a lot of water this thing
is filling up
go ahead trisha try that it's really
good
that nice daddy
yeah he makes things so weird okay
there's a paper towel do you not like it
like i liked it
you're struggling the things you say hmm
daddy
i don't like it how do you not like
that's my favorite
that's my favorite yeah i love that
wow there's paper towels i want to get
in the bath of this stuff kind of
the water feels so like relaxing and
nice and it's like you should take a
bath in this
that should be the best episode once
it's squished down like this i'm not
into it anymore though
paper towel all right now i hate it on
my feet oh thank you
thank you thank you hmm it is like
relaxing though
it's like it's so cold and nice i don't
like the mush bucket i like it pure
the mush bucket oh my god right next
so we're making slime i've never made
slime
okay i know it's like we're making slime
this looks like slime already this looks
like it's already made
what is that so that that's just glue
why would you just assume you can it's
probably you can't eat it
because kids play with it no it's if
it's kid's safe it's trish you're safe
so that's okay yeah you'll be fine
that's the consistency that you're
aiming for is that thing you got your
hand
on there this is our goal yeah so see
that big bottle in front of you
oh crap yeah the elmer's yeah you want
to add
a couple t uh teaspoons at a time daddy
here yes that's what you say no i said
it one time and it was because you're
weird
daddy here play with this yeah
i don't think that's the point i think
we're supposed to be making this i think
we're gonna have a goal to attain
i want you to know what your goal is
goal obtained
[Music]
watch out with a knife oh my god
it's always the people that people think
are normal they're the ones that kill
people people think
you know what you know what i disagree
lately i've
i've i've changed the saying too it's
always the people you most
expect absolutely that's very not true i
feel like it's 100
gajillion percent true
it's always people you most expect no
it's gonna be you that murder somebody
exactly it's gonna be you
all right what do we do all right so
that big bottle in front of you the glue
yeah you want to add like maybe two
teaspoons at a time
until you get that nice slime
consistency got measuring things too but
that seems about right you don't want to
go too gloomy
what is this stuff magic liquid elmer's
to make some oh this is just to make
slime yeah elmer's is
probably on this [ __ ] i didn't even know
elmore's was still around
elmer's got special slime so what so
what is
it it's just slime juice that's to make
it kind of crunchy and
and crispy yeah but you want to mix it
up too
like i like my glue of crunchy like my
chicken
you don't even like chicken you told me
you don't like chicken last time i like
chicken what do you know you don't act
like you know anything about me
i do you're like i don't like mac and
cheese i don't like chicken and i said
i'm gonna be making cheese and chicken
you're like oh i could pass that meal i
was like okay
elitist you literally don't know
anything about me you literally said
that last time
[Music]
that's a lot okay news a lot man
you're gonna lose i love that you lose
all the competitions in front of me
and the only way you win is by cheating
[Laughter]
this is the opposite of satisfying this
is so stressful i feel
my satisfying get me thank you mine
feels good i don't know what y'all are
on about
i got the goo i got the what is the [ __ ]
that was in the bowl already
that was glue oh so you mixed the their
glue
dude elmer has got this this vertical
rock yeah they've got the glue and the
magic glue
i think i need more something i don't
think you need more anything you
literally took everything
i think i need more magic solution or
glue or something
this is mine's satisfying this is not
satisfying me
this is horrific it looks kind of cool
though
no can yours can you slime it out or no
ew yours is not satisfying it's way too
much yours isn't gooey though it's not
slimy like this
this is like a [ __ ] dude i'm just
saying this is like your ball sack
that's true my balls have been drooping
in my older i can imagine i can tell
that energy from you
oh it's inevitable it's not inevitable
i've been with people that were 50 years
old and have tight ones
well it gets well sometimes it's tight
sometimes it's loose
oh it's just welcome to the male anatomy
hello
maybe yours not every male don't speak
for every minute oh we all as far as i'm
aware gravity affects us all and you
should know something about that
what's that mean i don't know figure it
out my boobs are saying
i don't know well that is an issue that
you know women have to deal with
that's why you get a lift i've gotten
three already and i need another one
here put that in i'm in what and your br
i found got your new image oh that's
pretty
okay which one's more satisfying i mean
yours is really
too runny but that's the point no but
this one's thick and like
look this one is like there's goodbye
not satisfying this
is satisfying okay daddy oh my god
you're the one saying this weird kink
here you want to tell me which one's
more status i think i need more magic
ew
this [ __ ] ain't magic
okay let's have an asmr battle like
everything okay let's do it here
battle listen relax
everybody relax turn up the volume
no people at home not you dude
okay and come tell me whose is more
satisfying
come on impartial impartial judge on the
satisfaction level
take this oh i don't like that
that's pretty good okay i always win
always always always always
how can we win every competition we do
because you're the best thank you
that was nice of you will you try at
least to hold mine
no it's not satisfying it really isn't
it makes me feel like words are on my
hand
all right i'll try yours i don't like
yours it's too good it looks like it
feels like warts
that's that's what my balls look like
yours looks gross man
it's it's not good thank you finally not
getting hurt
i don't even like looking at it i don't
know it just bothers me
it looks diseased it does it's beautiful
[ __ ] dare sit here and judge my slime
it looks like this time is about
individuality it's about creating
creativity it's about expressing
yourself and for you all to sit here and
judge my slimes absolutely [ __ ]
disgusting you're all cancelled
your slime has smallpox that totally is
that was your tourette's or no stop what
are you you just went off on your entire
crew
and i don't know if that was real
tourette's or you were being funny
i guess that's part of my charm because
he just said draw fire you're all
canceled i'm like
is this joking he's joking
i'm gonna sound like one really you
think i'm canceling my crew over there
criticism of myself i think it might be
your condition
okay you're you're the neuro you're the
neurologist i watched your eyebrow
episode from years ago
yeah and because i never i never thought
it popped up after the h3 live and i'm
like let me click on this
oh yeah ethan's eyebrows because i have
like you guys but you don't do that
anymore that's what i'm saying did it
get cured
no because it used to be bad i went to
go watch some old ones it's like oh yeah
but you don't do that at all anymore i
watch our friends back no
it takes people with tourette's ticks
come and go in severity and they change
to different things so
it's not that it's cured or goes away
it's just ticks are
it's an odd condition it's like a
stutter
well no it's not like it's just it
changes like sometimes like i'll wiggle
my toes or something so
i break on my toes too maybe i have it
okay how come you don't talk about it
more i love talking about it i think
it's so interesting
i'm gonna talk about it what do you want
to know about it more stuff that jiggles
than wiggles
you want to know about this my jiggles
and wiggles how about what else
my dog bite wound is now covered in
slime and styrofoam and glitter are you
okay
and we'll find out do we have a cake
what's next let's get this slime out of
here
okay we're back and we've cleaned up
that mess and what do we have before us
so you've got elmer's goo elmer's make
make a little pile of it make a pile
dude when did elmer's take over the
whole goo
game yeah they're like killing it all
about the game they're like we used to
make glue
now we make goo that's so weird dude
they're stuck i'm gonna buy some elmer's
glue stock
that that goo money is probably crazy
you know what i'm saying i hear you oh
so what did i do why was i doing all
this magic [ __ ] when elm already made
perfect goo for me
it's not slime it's goo yeah it's not oh
it's a different phenomenon yeah yeah
that's that's clearly yeah totally
different phenomenon come on just so
happens elmer's got him both cornered
invest in elmer's i'm telling you ellen
is going to be top company in the world
soon
i don't and then i have a feeling
elmer's is owned by
somebody oh like i don't think elmer's
is publicly traded wait really
dan that's not the point are we
supporting like some evil or something
do you think it's owned by you didn't
tell me i was gonna have to look at
myself today ian
how do you look there's a mirror and i
was like oh
really i gotta look at myself now that
wasn't part of the challenge
yeah buddy dysmorphia i'm just kidding
do you like looking at yourself in the
mirror
i don't like it but i i don't uh you
don't shy away from it
i i yeah i mean i it used to bother me a
lot but now i
i feel like i'm just very passive about
it which is good
i'm happy with that i love that love
that we love mediocre
so what am i supposed to do with this
morphe james charles this is a rare this
is a collector's item would there
may not hopefully be many more of these
we're going to be destroying it okay so
use the little
clay tools or the fork and we're trying
to get this mirror out
[Music]
be careful with the oh my god ethan be
careful with the knife
okay we don't need to be seeing
ourselves
i think that's like the least
problematic part of this palette you
just threw out
okay now did we pay for this you guys
stole this right you steal this
how much was this piece
you bought it good how much was that oh
you bought it second half yeah
okay good good good good good second
hand nobody's operation how much is this
new
it's like 40 bucks dude no 40 bucks in
here so which tone do you think
best matches a 16 year old boy you
should do blacks or aesthetic
it's a black boy no you don't want to be
a 16 year old boy though like why do you
want an aesthetic of that
because it's james charles palette okay
but oh my god
okay i'm a black i'm a little i'm a
six-year-old black boy i'm according to
you
so i don't know if that's offensive well
you said it
i literally think it's a black color
because it's aesthetic okay here i'll
add some other pigment so that it's not
a racial thing what are we doing again
what is this
i think we're just we're we're kind of
coloring our heads and you you mush
the goo together and yeah we're going it
up
gooing it up i'm chanting on air and i'm
going it up
today this looks horrible i guess that
black was probably
picked black was probably a really bad
call well you can
you can tie dye it together i'll do it
i'll do a furniture color
oh yours goo is gonna be cooler thank
you
everything i do is cooler everything i
do is going daddy
oh my god what is are you penned up for
something you're so
extra today yeah you kind of got me
charged up with the logan paul [ __ ]
i didn't mean that kind of pent up
you're saying daddy and moaning after
everything we do
oh because it's funny is it i think it's
funny
that creeps me out when you do it if you
seen that tick tock where the guy goes
yeah
you silly goose yeah
no it's so funny i am not saying that
how have you not seen that it's a
different tick tock than me clearly
that's for sure
okay let me just goo it up ooh so this
is gonna be for our song pink and black
it's called
i have been writing it for real writing
a song about us yeah and it's the snl
inspiration we're doing it together you
said you were gonna do the music video
with me
oh i didn't know that you i mean i said
yes i didn't know that you had a concept
already we're inspired by snl short
parodies their songs
okay and why did the girl eat the last
i'm gonna take white because i need to
lighten it like black and yellow but
pink and black pink and black pink and
black pink and black
here let's see if the white helps
because i need to lighten the situation
up this is not good
i don't really know how this what's the
satisfying part the chalk or the slime
right a good question right i think it's
a bit of both
okay mine dude bro
this is just a mess this looks like the
butter i made a clump of coal
you told me to do black i thought that
was a good idea black and it looks fine
i don't know if it looks fine it looks
like a uterus
it's like a weird it looks like an alien
birth out of a
someone who's like impregnated by alien
and they're [ __ ] i'm not pregnant
this month i got my period
just didn't quite do too it's so i was
so
sad i like kind of cried yeah because i
was like seven days late and i thought
for sure and i was sick from the the
vaccine shot i'm like oh my god
i'm sick this is for sure it and then
well
you mean either went through so much
effort in this last month yeah and like
man
it's really sad ugh so
yeah i'm adopting anybody who wants
their kid adopted by me just reach out
to me anyways
yeah we're taking applications sure if
someone emails me and says
can you take my kid i would totally do
that because that kid needs saving
right you know i'm not sure can you just
do that can you just give your kid to
somebody yeah
can you really yeah people leave their
babies in a dumpster well
not like a but you're not asking for a
baby you're actually like a adult or
like a
child but you know like
like what if james charles wants to
adopt like a 15 year old bro you're a
doc
i know i was just gonna say you're
trying to adopt the same because james
is trying to molest
nobody there's a whole mark these kids
are in big demand these six-year-olds
allen adopted two kids with his new wife
suny i'm like how is that allowed he
married his last adopted daughter that
should give you hope
you if he can adopt you can't do it
you're like and do you have any credible
accusations that you are
sexually attracted to the kids he's like
yes they're like okay great
there's two options for you when i was
in the bathroom i thought of the opening
for my snl monologue it's going to be
you cutting your arm off but like fake
blood squirting everywhere
okay because that was the swarm included
okay yeah yeah i'm in
trista's fantasy i'm in tricia's fantasy
snl
oh you're gonna watch out i'm gonna be
the first person to
post it okay this
no piece of [ __ ]
wait did that wait you're so angry right
now
you triggered you threw that at my head
really hard
it didn't even hit you oh my god stop
being such a drama queen it literally
didn't hit you
okay but there's a knife close to you
okay all right you did it to me
it was just a light thing did it whack
my head
okay so that was just a lad thing all
right sorry let's move on let's forget
this happen
let's put the glue okay let's put the
glue back in the jar
oh
daddy daddy do you wanna hit me one more
time cause i did two
no i'm okay why not you're making me
feel bad you want me to be honest okay
if you want if you want me to yeah
because i did two right okay
sorry that was a little aggressive okay
i thought we were having i appreciate
the equality
i'm ready ready
i had your pants of course i was gonna
hit your face
we're equal there's no more hits you one
more time there's no no
there's no more slime whacking of fun
okay you can whack me really well tell
me where so i know to prepare
no that's not the fun part okay daddy
that was even on camera
what are you chewing trying to jerk me
off weirdo
everything's so gross well what are you
doing
daddy daddy
all right
that was not satisfying ooh it's like
nails on a chalkboard stop stop
what do we do so this one is pain mixing
just kind of get little little dabs of
color and kind of swirl them with them
so as i'm this is basically kindergarten
like i'll be satisfying is just you're
in kindergarten yeah
could you imagine if we went to
kindergarten
[Music]
what what's what am i imagining we'd
have the best snacks
our lunch boxes oh bro i used to hit
like uh lunchables
ah you did i had like with the crackers
and the cheese and the hams like oh
really
the little red stick i was i was
superior my mom sent me to school with a
happy meal
she gave me mcdonald's chicken nuggets
from the day before and i had fries in
the box
wait you had a day old happy meal oh i
loved it and kids loved it too like you
have mcdonald's and i was like yeah you
have a little peanut butter and sandwich
[ __ ] sounds like child abuse
are you kidding me everyone thought it
was so cool that i had mcdonald's like
my mom got it the night before and put
it in the freezer it was illegal
send your kid with dale mcdonald's to
school
that was the cool thing i was the cool
kid i had the best everyone was like
sometimes it feels cool to be a beaut
okay and i'm just going to i don't want
to get in too seriously yeah let's not
because i think you have more trauma
from your family than i did my family
was amazing
okay i'm not competing it's not a
traumatic body shamed me not a body
shaming olympics
not a body i mean not a trauma olympics
just because your parents unless you
have fast food they shamed you i have
fast food all the time what are you
talking about
or they said oh you're too skinny my
parents never said i was too skinny
are you probably i just i just find it
odd that your mom would
freeze a happy meal we i would get it
the night before and we'd get it and
would you rock with the toy would you
save the toy or would you
yeah because they thought it was a fresh
one what would you
would you get the toilet the day before
would you open it at school with
lunchables that's more child abuse those
are toxins in there it causes
infertility
it's what causes infertility
yeah whoa that's a revolution would you
read that
i read that in my infertility google
search well like processed meats and
stuff
um you mean like chicken nuggets no
how's your color going oh you didn't you
wait oh you're just swirling
that's what he literally said to do is i
was trying to make like a pigment you
know what i mean i'm trying to like make
i'm trying to actually
make a pigment over here so here let's
we'll get some white in there going for
kind of like a salmon
kind of like a fall
this is more of a fall i immediately
stepped back from that
it's more of a a beautiful
autumn kind of cream
right you see it
i'm doing a hidden mickey you know
yeah it looks like a diary on a plate
mine looks like a picasso mickey
hey once we get all vaccinated do we get
to do the can i be a part of the h3
disney chip
oh definitely you'll be there really
would you ride a gatsby
what's a guess oh like a mobility
scooter i want us all to go on mobility
so no that's like ablest i think it
looks like a rolls royce
well i think there's something again it
is ableish right yeah
but i definitely yeah you're i
definitely would invite you and moses
okay great
otherwise we'll go the same day and get
another vip trip and make sure that
we're i wouldn't hate it
guys yeah that'd be awesome well we'll
be on mobility scooters yours will be
in our dust oh and then i'm going to
tweet about it you'll get canceled we
should like we'll both be on pirates
like both to boat be like
[ __ ] talking [ __ ] and throwing stuff
pirates that's my favorite ride there
yeah it's kind of just chill right you
just hang out there i like anything
chill
my last vip tour guy told me that
leonardo dicaprio
would smoke on the pirates of the
character and she wouldn't stop him
because he's too famous
are you serious i swear to god you heard
that right then
can we cancel another dicaprio for that
but i i mean i guess he was vaping
she said he was vaping oh my god but
that just fits right in
leonardo dicaprio bothers me he's like
50. because he dates like
18 year olds yeah his dating his dating
record is pretty bad
and you're not cute anymore okay stop it
they're obviously just like after you
because you're leo you're no brad pitt
let's put it that way you got a little
puppy i mean he still looks good but
it's time to date someone above the age
of 25. welcome to the puffy but it
doesn't feel bad to be
like what's the age he hasn't dated
anyone over like 26 or something
it's like something like that you got to
be his girlfriend and you're coming
close you're like oh boy you start
sweating what's wrong with you leonardo
capra there's something wrong with you
you sicko
he likes young girls ugh at least
there's nothing wrong with him
at least there were 18 more i could say
manipulation power control power
manipulation i agree i mean
you know gross date your own age so now
what we're going to do to spice this up
a little bit
add a little bit of spice you don't want
to make a cube
i literally made a mickey mouse what are
you talking about you don't want to make
a hue
like a color first of all look at all
the colors ethan gets
pink orange use my colors look at my
colors brown
poop white mustard here what the heck
i wanted a pink that's why mine looks
like eggs now we're going for salmon we
got
the green in there we're gonna mix it up
right you're supposed to swirl it
okay i'm over this this [ __ ] looks like
a nightmare your [ __ ] looks like a
[ __ ]
paralysis demon oh i had one of those
the other night
the voices in my head tell me don't do
it
oh they don't say don't do it that's
good right
no don't do this project because the
paint can be a little um
what's it called like when you get high
off paint a little huffy oh
oh that sounds fun i'm you don't feel it
i'm feeling it sorry
i feel like i'm out of this thing
because i feel like the slime maybe they
gave you the toxic [ __ ]
well i think from the get-go i got a
little i'm out
trish is on some weird [ __ ] that needs
to be analyzed by a psychologist oh my
god look who's talking you literally
isn't a blob
i was trying to make a hue self-portrait
so deep bruh sit don't throw that out
you're gonna save that portrait
save that your blob don't throw that
don't throw this out
frame that make sure to sign it
thank you i actually made something so
this one's called paint boring
paint boring pouring i was like boring
you have all the colors you put in a you
know a bunch of different ones in your
jar
mm-hmm on top of each other and then you
slowly pour it on your yeah
oh i like that i like that that's very
nice so you mix it all in one jar
yeah and you don't swirl it up you kind
of put it on top of each other oh that's
gonna be nice that's gonna be very
satisfying
mm-hmm i hope you're satisfied got it
wait that one's like empty oh so should
i not put a lot cause that one has like
nothing in it
i don't know yeah not a lot fascinating
this is satisfying just watching it drip
in there actually i love watching like
this is the watching paint dry up yeah i
know
i was just thinking that too this is the
episode i always dreamed about making
i'm going dark colors i hope this is our
most viewed uh podcast so we do this
again
it won't be you don't think
no why would it be watching too big
can i mention one more thing about
impulse ever know
listen this is your show right um they
said they filmed the jeff weddick
episode and they're like well
it seems a little bit outdated now but
we're going to put it up next week
so they filmed it before our friend well
that's nothing new he's apparently
recording episodes
four months ahead of time so they're
gonna put it out it's just so stupid
dude
i can't wait to hear though i'm sure he
like said wait so this was before he
came on and got yeah
roasted yeah oh boy yeah talk about
dated
so they're like but we're going to share
this why would you publish that why
would you publish that
that's that's insane for two months
training also jeff has got to be like
please don't post that like i've already
gone through this
i already apologize and it's gonna be
some all that [ __ ] of him being like
well uh the article was written for
money like you know what i mean like
his defense is always me like trish is
not credible i'm like oh i wonder if he
says anything that's so interesting well
it's fine people still keep discrediting
me all the time did he
why are you already pouring anything oh
i thought i wasn't supposed to mix it
[ __ ] i thought it was oh [ __ ] okay
yep here can i get it back in
look at what look at trisha's jar layer
it look at trisha's jar put it in the
jar and then you pour it
don't do it i don't mind i layered it be
careful with the paint because
um you get it on the oh okay i didn't
like these other colors but okay here
i'll do it your guys way i'll follow the
rules
everyone wants me to follow the rules
painting how come this one's empty
there you go it's just the same colors
oh my god you're gonna get the table
stained and they just said be careful
okay now what
then you slowly pour it on the canvas
that's what i was doing
but you hadn't mixed it but you had you
only have one color in your i had three
colors they were dark colors doing
something artistic
now i got all these colors i don't even
like okay
this is too fast i mean like phone okay
yeah this is epic someone's going to
want to buy this
let me turn this into an nft real fast
cool it's all green
you literally call it all my beautiful
colors
oh you're supposed to do it like that
what i feel like you know this stuff
this wasn't properly she just listened
yeah [ __ ]
you've seen this on tickets i actually
have never but i'm just like
why how he didn't say i think that's
satisfying just i don't even know if
this is satisfying i'm just doing it
because it looks better than what you're
doing at least it just looks like some
movement
you set me up i don't think i did well
here
hold on hold on maybe there's something
interesting below because it's all
oh my god it's all just green you guys
is that going all over the table
no one's buying that no it's not it's
not it's well b just do it over there
just do it over the white it is over the
white it's not on the table
underneath this green there's a
masterpiece yeah
you're right it's just hidden
it's the occluded masterpiece here let
me sign it
can i sell it ethan can i take it ethan
was here these will both be available
and nfts only
nfts man yours
once again i'm improving my my merits as
an artist here
i'm oddly satisfied oh my god what was
that thing you sent me
about that author of americans like how
did you know the author of american
psychopath
well i was kind of impressed i was like
okay intellectual over here i just liked
that quote
and so how did you know he was the
author of his name because i looked up
who he was
yeah i was so impressed i felt like we
were having an intellectual conversation
that day i was like well
and then you do stuff like this and i'm
like oh my god dumb ass
you've seen this on tick tock i swear i
i just you're like am i
is this how you envision it because i
don't even know i was putting i was
did i was putting the colors in so
carefully
i was like dark hues interesting two
minutes and then you all got [ __ ] all
crazy on my ass i was doing my own thing
and i had to scoop it back into the jar
well i apologize i did not see that
there were multiple colors in there
exactly
so you underestimate me i'm an idiot
dark green and dark blue
you think i'm an idiot
and i wish that um me are you telling me
or dan
dan oh because i too think you're an
idiot so i guess you weren't suggesting
me sometimes you're like an idiot savant
i agree
like sometimes you're super dumb and
then sometimes you're just like hyper
smart are you really calling anyone a
savant i mean what is gravity like stop
i'm a savant too i agree yeah okay
couple two two savants
two fat savants the the lines are doing
you some favors here though ethan that's
that looks a lot more satisfying the
last episode i really wanted
he even gave me titles and one of them
was like two fatties arguing and i
wanted that so bad i was so sad you
didn't
go with that title i loved it oh because
i thought
i thought that um some people might
i don't know be upset yeah be upset some
people some
i was thinking of titling the last
episode two fatties arguing for two
hours
i mean no one's fatter than us that's
for sure nope
we're fat you're fat i look well you're
fat fat fat fatty fat first of all
that's from a mel brooks movie and
everyone's stupid for not knowing it's
from the producers both versions of um
gene wilder said it and matthew
broderick said it's nathan lane fat fat
fatty that is and so people who thought
that was my original you guys are stupid
and not cultured
mel burks wrote that line but okay i'll
take the credit for it
beautiful like i said savant and also
fat all right we only have a few more
minutes so uh if there's some more
we have one more okay probably got one
more perfect this time so sad that this
chin turned out good hold on
don't put red on it well let's just
let's just make a period
oh like that my unborn baby
well that's why eggs are eggs that
didn't fertilize i'm not going to be
more able to
i'm not trying to ask what eggs are i'm
just saying stop stop the madness right
now i'm triggering you
okay
[Music]
daddy
much better ethan all right get this out
of my face
oh my god that's what i'm talking about
that sounds like tourette's where you're
like happy one minute and then like get
this on my face like you just sound
crazy
you literally don't know anything about
tourette's i think i do
i'm on tour at tic-tock all the time
it's crazy is that i find that so odd
what is yeah
it's like them trying to get kova tests
and they can't like you know they can't
keep still from are you sure
i haven't found these people are faking
it for views no it's real
people have really severe cases i know
someone who got like a whole brain
surgery for their tourette's
moses was there at the recording studio
when they were telling us about it he
paid like a million dollars to get his
like brain rewired he had like a severe
case of tourette's i don't
okay i'm not gonna question whatever you
think you saw
that sounds questionable story so you
are questioning
it yeah i i am big time huge question
like i'm not gonna question it
that really doesn't make sense okay
i think that's called a lobotomy what
you're describing no
oh my god it wasn't that cake time
grand finale i love cake smashing
so what is the theory here what is this
um i like the cake smash where you go
straight down like just don't even
question it straight down
are these little candy diamonds that's
awesome wait can i eat these
um yeah probably can i eat this
yeah you can do whatever you want yeah
is it like it's white chocolate
really try the diamond
oh mine's hard i can't eat it i think
just give it up
just dedicate just commit to it
so ian what are we supposed to do just
smash yeah we saw this on
trisha's tick-tock oh you did it yeah
you did a smash i had like 10 million
views so you go first because i always
go first and look like an idiot i'm so
excited
you got 10 million views for this
hit it hit it hit it hit it oh my god
your arm is shaking you're like
going for it
wow wow
oh cheeses wow
that's a cupcake i got mine from madonna
that was a powerful cake
it was a little tough okay all right
here we go
it just sounds yeah
i want a perfect like handprint you know
what i mean
but squeeze now squeeze squeeze squeeze
through your fingers make a fist make a
fist
make a fist
that's good they're kind of cold no no
no i hate no shade but they're a little
cold so i think if they were softer like
they were a little out but they're
oh i see but it was good i loved it i
mean
i haven't treated myself to anything in
a long time
what's a long time it's a week long i'm
in a week a couple days ago a week
like nothing i haven't strayed from the
from the path in a week
honestly though this [ __ ] is obama
where is the cake from this is done let
me hit that chip
i think it's just ralph's finest baby
ralph's is good ross is good cake is
this ralph's
i think he's from about civilians that's
even bougier pavilions
this is the segment this is the one that
goes totally off the rails
oh you're not helping people the people
with eating disorders
when they watch our video they like to
it helps them it's like when i work out
with impulsive
every time i'm doing it for you guys
first bite on tic tac hey guys
are you having trouble taking your first
bite we're here to help let's do it
together
ready one two three it's for people who
don't eat enough mm-hmm oh i thought it
was for fat they feel guilty
we feel guilty eating food and they
can't take that first bite they need
someone to help them oh really
i had that problem when i had binging
disorder if i binged
the night before i just would starve
myself the next day but you're really
supposed to eat every day
have one bite you know okay this is for
all you guys
it doesn't need to be sexual it doesn't
have to be like that just you know
all right let's try a second bite now
ready
oh i'm supposed to be like a trainer
yeah i like your cake better i know it's
so much better okay guys here we go
it's like the ant the anti-peloton yeah
okay guys get ready here we are it's
monday
you know what we're gonna do we're gonna
eat some cake here we go we're gonna
take that first bite together
get ready you need the food come on now
guys let's just eat the cake
chew it and get it down you're not gonna
regret it
okay but now you don't money baby money
baby
i know
okay but that's you know what you might
have an eating disorder i do when i went
to
i went to a rehab for it for real
because i had a problem where i was like
binging and then i was like puking it up
or whatever and the thing is
it's called food guilt and you're not
supposed to have any your body needs
food
if you have a sweet once in a while like
you've been doing so good don't feel
guilty about it after
i know you and i know you're to feel
guilty and bad she's really sad
don't do it let me hit this
it's not a drug don't say let me hit
this it is
just we're both we're more addicted to
cake than we are [ __ ] anything
your body needs food that's the problem
and go eat healthy after this you can
have a salad tonight you know if you do
you know whatever
just balance here watch this i'm gonna
eat this tomorrow watch this
let's all turn like a little cake turd
here ready
do a cake turd with me i'm not come on
i i politely declined come on do a cake
turn with me you put a candlestick up
your butt what's this
you bring it up every time is that the
same though
okay ready cake joy and cake is not the
same as cake turd
right
this is where you lose me though i think
you're so funny until you like then do
foot army this stuff it's like oh
you lose me foot army got rylan a one
you should be thanking me
rylan checked his wiki feet and he's
like i have a one
you should find that so funny i think he
needs to be checking himself before he's
checking wikipedia he's kind of the
worst human being alive he lied straight
up on camera to all his audience and
facebook okay
like i feel like i think he's not trying
to give me credit he has a one
i think you're trying to take away from
ryland being a horrible ship
you really think that's what i'm doing
on wikipedia hmm
this is a disney evil person
you know how um you know how disney you
see people with giant turkey legs
they should have a bucket full of cake
and you just put your hand in and then
you see people cruising around disney
like this and go
hmm what are we going to do next i love
disney food
and a cake and a god and a cake
i like it that can be ours i said fine
off campus cake and a cake
or that's only one god you know the
kardashians say bible we can be
handicapped
they say bible when you're like swearing
on something you're like bible it's 100
the truth
or as david says dead ass we're going to
do that yeah his is like you don't go
back on dead ass like dead ass means
it's real like that's their thing
and if you go back on that like they'll
never trust you again so if you say dead
ass it has to be real so ours can be
palm cake candy cake
cake on cake handy cake all right we're
we're out of time i'll put that in my
lyrics we're going to wrap it up
and the cake candy cake guys circle
alive
this cake met that the back side of the
circle alive
okay thanks for watching and we'll see
you next time on
[Music]
frenemies
you